RELEASED IN JULY 2023, TITLED
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY, IT
DID NOT ADEQUATELY OR
CONSISTENTLY ADDRESS SOME
ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. AS YOU'LL NOTICE ON
THE AGENDA, WE'LL FIRST HEAR
FROM STATE AUDITOR MR. PARKS,
WHO WILL PRESENT THE RESULTS OF
THE AUDIT, AS WELL AS THE STATUS
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE
AUDITS, RECOMMENDATIONS. CSU
CHANCELLOR DOCTOR GARCIA AND
ASSOCIATE VICE CHANCELLOR MISS
SCHWARZKOPF WILL FOLLOW THE
STATE AUDITOR. THE FINAL PANEL
WILL CONSIST OF STAKEHOLDERS,
INCLUDING REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE CAL STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION, CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES UNION AND
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
THEIR PERSPECTIVES ARE VITAL ON
THIS TOPIC AS THEY OFTENTIMES
REPRESENT THE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. LIKE MANY
CALIFORNIANS, I'VE BEEN
DISHEARTENED BY THE MANY CASES
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AT CSU
CAMPUSES IN RECENT YEARS.
UNDERSTANDABLY, THESE INCIDENTS
MAY CAUSE MANY CAL STATE
STUDENTS, FACULTY AND STAFF TO
LOSE TRUST IN THE UNIVERSITY'S
ABILITY TO KEEP THEM SAFE. I
APPRECIATE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR'S THOROUGH EXAMINATION
OF HOW THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM HANDLES
ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. THIS REPORT IS A
CRITICAL TOOL FOR ENSURING
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE REPORT HIGHLIGHTS SEVERAL
AREAS WHERE CSU CAMPUSES DID NOT
ADEQUATELY OR CONSISTENTLY
ADDRESS ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. THE AUDITOR FOUND
GAPS IN HOW CSU HANDLES
COMPLAINTS, INCLUDING AN
INADEQUATE INVESTIGATION,
INCONSISTENT APPLICATION OF
POLICIES AND INSUFFICIENT
DOCUMENTATION AND ISSUANCE OF
DISCIPLINARY DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS. SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE THAT AFFECTS THE
SAFETY, DIGNITY AND WELL-BEING
OF STUDENTS, FACULTY, AND STAFF.
THE PREVALENCE OF SUCH BEHAVIOR
UNDERMINES THE FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES OF RESPECT AND
EQUALITY THAT ARE ESSENTIAL TO A
PRODUCTIVE AND INCLUSIVE
EDUCATIONAL SETTING. THUS, IT'S
CRITICAL THAT CSU CAMPUSES
RESPOND TO ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SWIFTLY, EFFECTIVELY,
AND CONSISTENTLY. IT'S BEEN A
YEAR SINCE CSU LEADERSHIP
EXPRESSED THE UNIVERSITY'S
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES OUTLINED IN THE AUDIT
REPORT. MY GOAL FOR THIS
OVERSIGHT HEARING IS TO SHED
LIGHT ON CSU'S PROGRESS IN
IMPLEMENTING THE IMMEDIATE
STEPS, AS WELL AS THE LONG TERM
REFORMS NEEDED TO ENSURE A SAFE
AND RESPECTFUL ENVIRONMENT AT
ITS 23 CAMPUSES. I'M COMMITTED
TO WORKING CLOSELY WITH CSU
LEADERSHIP TO IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT. AS
PART OF THIS, I'M COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTIVE LEGISLATION AND
POLICY INITIATIVES AIMED AT
IMPROVING HOW INSTITUTIONS LIKE
CSU CAN HANDLE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. THIS INCLUDES
ADVOCATING FOR INCREASED
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES. THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
BILLS CURRENTLY IN THE
LEGISLATURE, INCLUDING MY OWN AB
2407 THAT ARE AIMED AT
ESTABLISHING RIGOROUS OVERSIGHT
MECHANISMS SUCH AS REGULAR
AUDITS, PERIODIC REVIEWS AND
PROGRESS REPORTS TO HOLD THE CSU
SYSTEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR ITS
ACTIONS. I LOOK FORWARD TO A
ROBUST DISCUSSION AND ENGAGEMENT
FROM ALL PARTIES TODAY BEFORE
PROCEEDING FURTHER. I HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM EVERYONE.
I ASK THAT THE PANELS KEEP THEIR
PRESENTATIONS TO THE TIME
ALLOCATED. THAT'S APPROXIMATELY
15 MINUTES FOR THE STATE
AUDITOR'S PRESENTATION. WE'LL
THEN HAVE APPROXIMATELY 15
MINUTES FOR THE CSU CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE TO RESPOND. AND LASTLY,
WE'LL HAVE FIVE MINUTES TO HEAR
FROM EACH PARTICIPANT ON THE
LAST PANEL. FOLLOWING EACH PANEL
PRESENTATION, MEMBERS WILL HAVE
TIME TO ASK QUESTIONS, AND WE'LL
RESERVE TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
AFTER THE PANEL'S LAST Q&A
PERIOD. MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH
THE PRESENTATIONS? I'M ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE OPENING COMMENTS? THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH, CHAIR
HART. AND TO EACH AND EVERY ONE
OF YOU WHO GATHERED HERE TODAY
TO REALLY CONTINUE TO PROVIDE A
PLATFORM FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
HEAR DIRECTLY FROM THE CSU AS TO
THE WORK IN RESPONSE TO THE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS. A
YEAR AGO, WE HEARD FROM THE
STATE AUDITOR ON THEIR FINDINGS
OF HOW THE CSU HAD FAILED TO
PRODUCE PROPER GUIDANCE FOR
CAMPUSES AND FAILED TO PROPERLY
REGULATE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
ITS SEXUAL HARASSMENT POLICY
ACROSS THE SYSTEM. AS WE HEARD
FROM OUR CHAIR, WE HEARD THE
DEEP DISAPPOINTMENT AND
TREMENDOUS CONCERNS FROM
FACULTY, STAFF AND STUDENTS ON
THE TRUST GAPS THAT HAVE BEEN
CREATED BETWEEN A SYSTEM AND ITS
COMMUNITY. A LOT CAN HAPPEN IN
12 MONTHS. IN FEBRUARY OF THIS
YEAR, THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE PUBLISHED A
CALL TO ACTION REPORT WHICH
DETAILED HOW THE STATE CAN PLAY
AN ACTIVE ROLE IN PARTNERING AND
SUPPORTING HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS TO FURTHER PREVENT
AND ADDRESS SEXUAL HARASSMENT ON
OUR CAMPUSES. AS A RESULT, 12
BILLS WERE INTRODUCED BASED ON
THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
COMMITTEE'S REPORT. THANK YOU TO
MY COLLEAGUES, INCLUDING CHAIR
HART AND COLLEAGUES HERE, FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP AND LEADERSHIP
IN ADDRESSING TITLE NINE THROUGH
THIS BILL PACKAGE. THE BILLS
WILL UNPACK ALL PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS, AND I
WOULD BE REMISS IF NOT, THANK
THE CSU FOR THEIR INPUT IN
DRAFTING OF THE REPORT, AS WELL
AS THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE
AND BEING THOUGHTFUL PARTNERS IN
THIS BILL PACKAGE. AS THE AUTHOR
OF TWO OF THE BILLS IN THE CALL
TO ACTION BILL PACKAGE, ASSEMBLY
BILL 247 AND ASSEMBLY BILL 248,
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE PARTNERSHIP
OF THE CSU, AND I'M EAGER TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT HOW THE CSU HAS
BEEN PARTNERING WITH THE STATE
TO IMPLEMENT REFORMS AND TO
ADDRESS THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE 2023 AUDIT. THANK YOU AGAIN
TO MY COLLEAGUES AND THANK YOU
TO CHAIR HART. THANK YOU. CHAIR
FONG. SEN NEWMAN, DO YOU HAVE
ANY OPENING COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE
TO MAKE? YES. JUST VERY BRIEFLY.
SO THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR. I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR'S OVERVIEW
AND YOUR VERY CLEAR ARTICULATION
OF THE CONTEXT AND BACKGROUND
FOR TODAY'S HEARING. THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUE, MR. FONG AS
WELL FOR HIS COMMENTS. I AM VERY
PLEASED TO SEE CHANCELLOR GARCIA
HERE TODAY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM THE CSU ABOUT ITS
IMPLEMENTATION OF AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ITS
CONTINUED EFFORTS TO FOSTER A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL MEMBERS
OF THE UNIVERSITY COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
PANELISTS FOR BEING HERE TO
ENGAGE WITH US IN THIS SOMETIMES
UNCOMFORTABLE DISCUSSION. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE CSU STAFF
FOR MAKING THEMSELVES AVAILABLE
TO MEET WITH OUR COMMITTEE STAFF
ON HOW CSU AND EACH OF ITS
CAMPUSES ARE IMPLEMENTING THE
AUDIT RECOMMENDATIONS. I'M GOING
TO HAVE TO LEAVE VERY BRIEFLY TO
VOTE IN SENATE ELECTIONS, BUT
I'LL BE BACK. BUT I LOOK FORWARD
TO A ROBUST DISCUSSION TODAY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU.
SEN. NEWMAN, ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM OR OPENING
STATEMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE? ALL RIGHT. WELL THANK
YOU. WE'LL START THEN WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR. PARKS, WOULD YOU
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION?
WELCOME. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REPORT. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR.
HEART CHAIR. CHAIR. HE WAS HERE.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TODAY
TO DISCUSS MY OFFICE'S JULY 2023
AUDIT OF THE CSU'S POLICIES AND
PRACTICES FOR INVESTIGATING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. MICHELLE
SANDERS WITH ME. SHE'S ONE OF MY
OFFICE'S AUDIT PRINCIPALS, AND
SHE LED THE AUDIT ASSIGNMENT AND
WILL BE INSTRUMENTAL IN
ANSWERING ANY DETAILED QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION STATUS OF OUR
REPORT'S VARIOUS
RECOMMENDATIONS. AS THE CHAIR
NOTED, SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS
CLEARLY A SERIOUS ISSUE THAT
INVOLVES UNWELCOME BEHAVIOR,
SUCH AS INAPPROPRIATE COMMENTS
OR PHYSICAL TOUCHING, WHICH CAN
CAUSE STUDENTS OR EMPLOYEES
EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL HARM THAT
INTERFERES WITH THEIR ABILITY TO
BENEFIT FROM OR WORK SAFELY
WITHIN A UNIVERSITY. JUST BY WAY
OF CONTEXT, AT THE TIME WHEN
JLARC AUTHORIZED THE AUDIT, THE
CSU SYSTEM HAD BEEN THE FOCUS OF
VARIOUS HIGH PROFILE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CASES. SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY HAD FACED AN
INVESTIGATION BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE RELATED TO
ITS HANDLING OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS AGAINST A
FORMER ATHLETIC TRAINER. IN
ADDITION, THE FORMER CHANCELLOR
RESIGNED HIS POSITION IN
FEBRUARY 2022 AFTER MEDIA
REPORTED THAT HE MISHANDLED
SEXUAL HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS
DURING HIS TIME AS THE PRESIDENT
OF FRESNO STATE UNIVERSITY.
DURING OUR AUDIT PERIOD, CSU HAD
ROUGHLY 55,000 EMPLOYEES AND
RECEIVED ON AVERAGE, BETWEEN 150
TO 300 COMPLAINTS PER YEAR.
BETWEEN 2018 AND 2022, TOTALING
MORE THAN 1200 REPORTS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIMS AGAINST CSU
EMPLOYEES. AND THE CSU
INVESTIGATED 254 OF THESE
REPORTS, OR ROUGHLY 20% OF ALL
COMPLAINTS, AND SUBSTANTIATED
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ALLEGATIONS IN
98 OF THE 254 INVESTIGATIONS, OR
ROUGHLY 39% OF THE TIME WHEN
APPROVING THE AUDIT REQUEST,
JLAC DIRECTED MY OFFICE, AMONG
OTHER THINGS, TO REVIEW THE ROLE
OF THE CSU SYSTEM'S TITLE NINE
OFFICES OFFICE IN TERMS OF ITS
POLICIES AND PRACTICES. THEY
ASKED US TO REVIEW THE CSU'S
PROCESS FOR INVESTIGATING
ALLEGED SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
WHETHER THE INVESTIGATION
PROCESS WAS FREE FROM
INTERFERENCE. THEY ASKED US TO
LOOK AT THE REASONABLENESS OF
THE DISCIPLINE IMPOSED AND ALSO
TO EXAMINE CSU'S POLICIES FOR
RETREAT RIGHTS AND LETTERS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAD FOUND TO HAVE ENGAGED IN
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. OUR AUDIT
REPORT, ALTHOUGH WE OBTAINED A
LOT OF SYSTEM WIDE DATA THAT WE
INCLUDE IN THE APPENDICES OF OUR
REPORT, MOST OF OUR WORK FOCUSED
ON A SELECTION OF 40 SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS PERTAINING
TO EMPLOYEES AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE IN THREE CAMPUSES, WHICH
WERE FRESNO STATE, SAN JOSE
STATE AND SONOMA STATE. AND
OVERALL, OUR AUDIT FOUND
WEAKNESSES AT BOTH THE CAMPUS
LEVEL AND THE SYSTEM WIDE LEVEL
THAT COULD BE CATEGORIZED INTO
THREE MAIN PROBLEMS THAT WE
HIGHLIGHT IN OUR AUDIT REPORT.
FIRST, WE CONCLUDED THAT THE CSU
CAMPUSES WE VISITED STRUGGLED TO
ADEQUATELY AND CONSISTENTLY
INVESTIGATE ALLEGATIONS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. SECOND, WE
FOUND THAT CAMPUSES COULD NOT
ALWAYS DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY
CONSISTENTLY IMPOSED DISCIPLINE.
AND THIRD, WE FOUND THAT A
SIGNIFICANT CAUSE FOR THESE
INCONSISTENCIES WAS THE LACK OF
SYSTEM WIDE GUIDANCE AND
MONITORING BY THE FORMER
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. I'LL TALK
BRIEFLY A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
CONTENTS OF OUR REPORT BEFORE
MOVING INTO THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE FIRST POINT
ON THE INCONSISTENT APPROACH TO
INVESTIGATING CLAIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT, WE NOTED A VARIETY
OF PROBLEMS IN THIS AREA, AND
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ONES WAS THE
UNEXPLAINED CLOSURE OF
COMPLAINTS WITHOUT CONDUCTING
INVESTIGATIONS, DECIDING WHETHER
OR NOT TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION IS ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL STEPS IN RESPONDING TO
AN ALLEGATION. IT'S ONLY THROUGH
THE INVESTIGATION PROCESS THAT
YOU CAN DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT HAS OCCURRED,
AND THEREFORE, WHETHER OR NOT
DISCIPLINE IS WARRANTED. IN 11
OF THE 15 COMPLAINTS WE REVIEWED
WERE CSU OFFICIALS CLOSED
COMPLAINTS AT INTAKE WITHOUT
CONDUCTING AN INVESTIGATION. WE
FOUND THAT THE CSU OFFICIALS
LACKED CLEAR RATIONALES FOR
DOING SO. WE FOUND INSTANCES
WHERE THEY PREMATURELY CONCLUDED
THAT THE ALLEGED BEHAVIOR DIDN'T
CONSTITUTE SEXUAL HARASSMENT,
WHICH WE FOUND CONCERNING GIVEN
THE NATURE OF THE ALLEGATIONS
PRESENTED, WE FOUND THAT CSU
OFFICIALS DID NOT ALWAYS
DOCUMENT THE RATIONALE FOR
CLOSING CASES AND WE ALSO NOTED
NOTED INSTANCES WHERE THERE
WASN'T ANY CLEAR ATTEMPT TO
CONTACT OTHER INDIVIDUALS CITED
IN THE ALLEGATION, BASED ON
MATERIALS THAT WE FOUND IN THE
CASE FILE. IMPORTANTLY, WE ALSO
COULD NOT ALWAYS DETERMINE WHICH
CAMPUS OFFICIALS DECIDED TO
CLOSE A CASE PRIOR TO AN
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE CSU
POLICIES DID NOT REQUIRE A
SIGNATURE OR AN APPROVAL
PROCESS, AND AS A RESULT, IT
WASN'T ALWAYS CLEAR WHO HAD
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE DECISIONS
TO CLOSE CASES PRIOR TO AN
INVESTIGATION. CSU'S POLICIES
REQUIRE TITLE NINE COORDINATORS
TO DOCUMENT IN WRITING THE
DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER TO
CONDUCT AN INVESTIGATION, BUT
THE POLICY DIDN'T REQUIRE ANY
DOCUMENTED RATIONALE FOR THIS
IMPORTANT DECISION, WHICH IS IN
CONTRAST TO GUIDANCE WE SAW FROM
THE US DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WITH OTHER CAMPUSES AND THEIR
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS, FOR
EXAMPLE, WITH SAN JOSE STATE,
WHICH REQUIRES CLEAR DOCUMENTED
RATIONALES FOR NOT PROCEEDING
WITH AN INVESTIGATION OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. MOVING TO THE
INVESTIGATIONS THEMSELVES, WE
ALSO FOUND INCONSISTENCIES THAT
LED US TO QUESTION THE
CONCLUSIONS THAT WERE REACHED BY
CSU OFFICIALS. WE NOTED
WEAKNESSES IN SEVEN OF THE 21
INVESTIGATIONS WE REVIEWED, AND
EACH OF THOSE RESULTED IN CSU
CONCLUDING THAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ALLEGATIONS WERE NOT
SUBSTANTIATED. AT EACH OF THE
FOUR LOCATIONS WE VISITED, WE
ENCOUNTERED SITUATIONS WHERE CSU
OFFICIALS APPEARED TO USE AN
UNREASONABLY RESTRICTIVE
INTERPRETATION OF CSU'S
DEFINITION OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN ONE CASE, A CSU
EMPLOYEE PHYSICALLY TOUCHED A
COMPLAINANT'S STOMACH AND HIP IN
AN INTIMATE WAY AND SAID HE
THOUGHT THEY WOULD ALWAYS HAVE
SEX. BUT THE CSU INVESTIGATOR
WHO CONCLUDED THESE EVENTS DID
OCCUR FOUND THAT THE CONDUCT WAS
NOT SUFFICIENTLY SEVERE,
PERSISTENT OR PERVASIVE. WE ALSO
FOUND ISSUES WITH INVESTIGATORS
OMITTING PARTS OF ALLEGATIONS
FROM THE INVESTIGATION'S FINAL
ANALYSIS FOR EXAMPLE, A CSU
EMPLOYEE MADE INAPPROPRIATE
COMMENTS TO A COMPLAINANT ABOUT
HOW SHE DRESSED FREQUENTLY,
HUGGED HER, AND INSTEAD OF
SHAKING HANDS AND TOUCHED HER
HAIR WHILE KISSING, ANOTHER
STAFF MEMBER, THE INVESTIGATOR
CONCLUDED AGAIN THAT THIS
ACTIVITY TOOK PLACE, BUT FOUND
IT WAS NOT SUFFICIENTLY SEVERE,
PERSISTENT OR PERVASIVE, IN PART
BECAUSE THE COMPLAINANT WAS ABLE
TO CONTINUE WORKING AND AVOID
THE RESPONDENT, BUT WHEN WE
LOOKED IN THE INVESTIGATION
FILE, WE FOUND THAT THE
INVESTIGATION REPORT NOTED THAT
THEY OMITTED ANY ANALYSIS OF
OTHER ALLEGATIONS OF
INAPPROPRIATE TOUCHING, THAT THE
COMPLAINANT AND OTHER WITNESSES
BOTH TOLD THE INVESTIGATOR HAD
OCCURRED. IN RESPONSE TO OUR
CONCERNS OVER THE QUALITY OF ITS
INVESTIGATION, CSU INDICATED
THAT IT OFFERS TRAINING TO ITS
TITLE NINE COORDINATORS AND
PROVIDED MATERIALS WHICH IN OUR
VIEW WERE REASONABLY DETAILED
AND HELPFUL. BUT CSU OFFICIALS
ACKNOWLEDGED THEY DON'T REQUIRE
THEIR COORDINATORS TO ATTEND
THESE TRAININGS OR CONSULT THESE
MATERIALS. IN OUR VIEW, MORE
DETAILED GUIDANCE, SUCH AS
WHAT'S PROVIDED IN THE
TRAININGS, IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE CAMPUSES INVESTIGATE
ALLEGATIONS CONSISTENTLY AND
THOROUGHLY. AND WE ALSO BELIEVE
THE CSU SHOULD DEVELOP A
SECONDARY SUPERVISORY REVIEW
PROCESS TO ENSURE INVESTIGATIONS
ARE CONDUCTED IN A CONSISTENT
MANNER. ANOTHER PROBLEM WITH THE
INVESTIGATIONS IS WE OFTEN FOUND
MISSING DOCUMENTATION IN 24 OF
THE 40 CASES WE REVIEWED, WE
NOTED THE ABSENCE OF EVIDENCE OF
OUTREACH TO COMPLAINANTS AND
POTENTIAL WITNESSES. WE NOTED
THE ABSENCE OF RELEVANT EVIDENCE
THAT WAS REFERRED TO IN THE
INVESTIGATION, ABSENT INTERVIEW
NOTES. AND OFTEN WE FOUND
LACKING INFORMATION ON WHAT
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS OR DISCIPLINE
THE CSU IMPOSED, IF ANY, THAT
WERE FOLLOWED FOLLOWING A
FINDING OF A SUBSTANTIATED
ALLEGATION OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AT THE TIME OF OUR AUDIT, CSU
DID NOT REQUIRE OR DID NOT
ESTABLISH REQUIREMENTS SETTING
EXPECTATIONS FOR HOW
INVESTIGATORS SHOULD DOCUMENT
THEIR CASEWORK. AGAIN, GOING
BACK TO THE US DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, THEY NOTED THE
IMPORTANCE OF SUCH REQUIREMENTS
IN ITS 2021 RESOLUTION AGREEMENT
WITH SAN JOSE STATE, WHICH
REQUIRED THAT CAMPUS TO
CONSISTENTLY DOCUMENT INTERVIEW
NOTES, CORRESPONDENCE WITH THE
PARTIES INVOLVED, AND ANY
DISCIPLINARY ACTION THAT WAS
TAKEN. WE BELIEVE THAT KIND OF
STANDARD IS SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE APPLIED SYSTEM WIDE.
WE ALSO NOTED PROBLEMS WITH
TIMELINESS, AND 13 OF THE 21
INVESTIGATIONS WE REVIEWED, THEY
WERE NOT COMPLETED WITHIN THE
TIME FRAMES ESTABLISHED BY CSU
POLICY. GENERALLY SPEAKING, CSU
REQUIRES THAT THEIR
INVESTIGATIONS BE COMPLETED
WITHIN 100 AND WITHIN 100 DAYS.
BUT WE NOTED THAT 13 OF THE 21
INVESTIGATIONS THAT WE REVIEWED
WERE OVER THIS MARK, RANGING
FROM AS LITTLE AS 17 DAYS LATE,
WHILE WE FOUND THREE THAT WERE
OVER 200 DAYS LATE AND ONE
INVESTIGATION, IT TOOK MORE THAN
368 DAYS TO COMPLETE, AND WE
NOTED IN THE CASE FILE THAT THE
COMPLAINANT WAS EXTREMELY
CONCERNED AND, QUOTE, JUST
WANTED IT TO BE OVER. BUT THE
CSU INVESTIGATOR EXTENDED THE
INVESTIGATION FIVE DIFFERENT
TIMES, CITING OTHER WORK
COMMITMENTS OR NEEDING
ADDITIONAL TIME TO PREPARE KEY
DOCUMENTS. WE ALSO NOTED THAT
ALL 13 CASES THAT WERE LATE, THE
CASE FILES LACKED DOCUMENTATION
TO DEMONSTRATE THAT THE PARTIES
INVOLVED WERE INFORMED OF THE
DELAYS ON A CONSISTENT BASIS OF
THEIR CASES, AND WE RECOMMENDED
THAT THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
CONSIDER EMPLOYING A POOL.
SYSTEM WIDE INVESTIGATORS TO
CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS WHEN
CAMPUSES MAY LACK THE RESOURCES
TO DO SO. TIMELY. AND WE ALSO
RECOMMENDED THAT THE CHANCELLOR
DEVELOP A METHOD FOR THE PARTIES
TO PERIODICALLY CHECK THE STATUS
OF THEIR COMPLAINTS THROUGH AN
ONLINE PORTAL, DASHBOARD, OR
THROUGH SIMILAR MEANS. TURNING
TO DISCIPLINE, WE ALSO FOUND
INCOMPLETE RECORDS IN TERMS OF
WHAT HAPPENED FOLLOWING
ALLEGATIONS AND SUBSTANTIATED
ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. DURING OUR REVIEW OF
THESE 40 CASES, WE FOUND SEVEN
WHERE THE CAMPUS CONCLUDED THAT
SOME FORM OF DISCIPLINE OR
CORRECTIVE ACTION WAS NEEDED,
BUT IT DID NOT INITIATE OR
DOCUMENT WHAT THAT CORRECTIVE
ACTION WAS. IN ONE
INVESTIGATION, WE REVIEWED, WE
FOUND A PROFESSOR IN 2016 WAS
FOUND TO HAVE ENGAGED IN SEXUAL
HARASSMENT, SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
STALKING OF A FEMALE STUDENT.
YET DESPITE THE FINDING, THE
UNIVERSITY DID NOT DISCIPLINE
THE PROFESSOR, EVEN THOUGH HE
HAD BEEN THE SUBJECT OF VARIOUS
COMPLAINTS SINCE 2003. NEARLY
THREE YEARS LATER, IN 2019, THE
CAMPUS DISCOVERED HAD MISSED THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
IMPOSING DISCIPLINE, AND THE
CAMPUS ULTIMATELY DIDN'T ISSUE A
LETTER OF REPRIMAND UNTIL MAY
2022. DURING THE AUDIT, WE NOTED
CSU SEXUAL HARASSMENT POLICY DID
NOT SPECIFY ANY TIME FRAMES FOR
INITIATING OR ADMINISTRATING,
ADMINISTERING DISCIPLINE OR
CORRECTIVE ACTION. FOR THOSE
FOUND TO HAVE VIOLATED CSU
SEXUAL HARASSMENT POLICIES. WE
ALSO EXAMINED RETREAT WRITES AND
LETTERS OF RECOMMENDATION
ADMINISTRATORS WHO VIOLATE CSU
SEXUAL HARASSMENT POLICIES AT
THE TIME OF OUR AUDIT WERE ABLE
TO RETREAT TO FACULTY POSITIONS
AS LONG AS THEY WEREN'T
TERMINATED OR SEPARATED FROM
EMPLOYMENT. DURING THE AUDIT, WE
FELT THAT THAT WAS A GAP IN THE
POLICY. WE ALSO FOUND THAT THE
CHANCELLOR SHOULD CONSIDER
REVISING CSU EMPLOYEES WITH
FINDINGS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
FROM RETREATING TO THESE
POSITIONS. BUT FOLLOWING OUR
REPORT, IT APPEARS TO US THAT
THE CSU CHANCELLOR HAS TAKEN
POSITIVE STEPS TO REVISE ITS
RETREAT POLICY AND NOW GENERALLY
PROHIBITS ADMINISTRATORS WITH
THE FINDING OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
FROM ACTUALLY RETREATING. WE
NOTED A SIMILAR POLICY GAP IN
THE CSU POLICIES FOR ISSUING
POSITIVE LETTERS OF
RECOMMENDATION. CSU'S POLICY AT
THE TIME OF THE AUDIT ALLOWED
LETTERS OF RECOMMENDATION FOR
THOSE WHO DID NOT SEPARATE OR
TERMINATE. BUT IN MARCH 2024,
AGAIN, WE NOTED THAT CSU CHANGED
ITS POLICY. WE THINK FOR THE
BETTER THAT NOW PROHIBITS
POSITIVE LETTERS OF REFERENCE
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE ENGAGED IN
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. IMPORTANTLY,
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT AB 1904
OR 1905 RATHER BY A MEMBER ADDS,
IF ENACTED, WOULD FURTHER CODIFY
CODIFY IN STATE LAW A
PROHIBITION ON RETREAT RIGHTS
AND LETTERS OF RECOMMENDATION
FOR EMPLOYEES OF A PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION IF
THEY'VE ENGAGED IN SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. AND THE LAST ISSUE I
TALK ABOUT IS, I THINK THE
GLOBAL CAUSE THAT WE FOUND IN
THIS AUDIT FOR THE
INCONSISTENCIES THAT WE NOTED
WITH SEXUAL HARASSMENT
INVESTIGATIONS, WAS THE LACK OF
CLEAR GUIDANCE AND MONITORING AT
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE LEVEL,
IN OUR VIEW, THE INSTANCES AND
THE INCONSISTENCIES THAT WE
FOUND WAS NOT THE RESULT OF
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES RELATED
TO SPECIFIC CASES, BUT INSTEAD
WAS THE LACK OF UNCLEAR
EXPECTATIONS AND OVERSIGHT AT
THE TIME COMING FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. YOU KNOW,
FOR EXAMPLE, THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND THE CAMPUS HAS
STRUGGLED TO COMPILE LISTS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS
THAT WAS NECESSARY FOR OUR AUDIT
WORK. AND THE CAMPUSES VARY IN
HOW THEY TRACK REPORTS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT, WE ALSO FOUND THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OFTEN
SUGGESTED THAT IT'S A BEST
PRACTICE FOR UNIVERSITIES TO
HAVE A CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM TO
SECURELY STORE COMPLAINTS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT SO THAT YOU
CAN ANALYZE AND MONITOR THAT
DATA ON A SYSTEM WIDE BASIS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE CSU DOESN'T
HAVE SUCH A SYSTEM, AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WE MADE IN OUR REPORT. BUT
HAVING DATA ISN'T ENOUGH. THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOME ONGOING
MONITORING, WE FOUND THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HADN'T HAD A
PRACTICE OF MONITORING CAMPUS
COMPLIANCE WITH TITLE NINE IN
THEIR SEXUAL HARASSMENT POLICIES,
EVEN THOUGH THAT THEY HAD MADE A
PREVIOUS COMMITMENT TO DOING SO.
IN 2014, MY OFFICE HAD
RECOMMENDED THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CONDUCT
ROUTINE REVIEWS OF CAMPUS
COMPLIANCE, BUT THEY HAD STOPPED
DOING THESE REVIEWS IN 2018,
DESPITE FINDING MANY OF THE SAME
KINDS OF ISSUES THAT WE NOTED IN
OUR MORE RECENT AUDIT IN 2023,
SUCH AS NOT ADDRESSING ALL THE
ISSUES RAISED IN A COMPLAINT AND
NOT PROPERLY ANALYZING EVIDENCE.
GIVEN THE CSU'S POLICY
DEFINITIONS IN TERMS OF
RECOMMENDATION STATUS. AND
AGAIN, MICHELLE CAN FILL IN MORE
OF THE DETAILS. BUT OVERALL, MY
OFFICE MADE 16 RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
ADDRESSING VARIOUS ISSUES FROM
INTAKE AND INVESTIGATION
PROCEDURES, TIMELINES, CASE FILE
DOCUMENTATION AND SYSTEM WIDE
DATA COLLECTION AND OVERSIGHT.
CSU HAS INDICATED THEY PLAN TO
IMPLEMENT ALL OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND AS OF OUR
CURRENT EVALUATION OF THEIR ONE
YEAR RESPONSE FROM LAST JULY, MY
OFFICE HAS CONCLUDED THAT THE
UNIVERSITY HAS IMPLEMENTED TEN
OF THE 16 RECOMMENDATIONS, WITH
SIX PENDING OR PARTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED. AGAIN, THE CSU HAS
INDICATED THEY PLAN TO IMPLEMENT
ALL OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS. AND
FURTHER, I WOULD NOTE THAT AB
1790, WHICH TAKES EFFECT IN
JANUARY AT A BASIC LEVEL,
REQUIRES THE CSU TO IMPLEMENT
ALL OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
ALSO, I WOULD NOTE THAT CHAIRMAN
HART'S BILL, AB 2407, IF
ENACTED, WOULD REQUIRE MY OFFICE
TO CONDUCT RECURRING AUDITS OF
THE CSU AND èC, WHICH MIGHT
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR MONITORING CSU'S
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS. GOING FORWARD,
BUT OVERALL, FOR THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE
REMAINING, FOR OUR, OUR PENDING
AND THEY SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTED
BY JULY 2026, IF NOT SOONER. AND
FOR THE TWO OTHERS THAT WE'VE
CLASSIFIED AS PARTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED, WE SEE THAT THE CSU
HAS ACTUALLY CREATED POLICIES,
BUT WE'RE JUST WAITING FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL TIME TO SEE THAT
THOSE POLICIES ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED IN PRACTICE. AND
THOSE ARE PRIMARILY CSU'S
MONITORING OF CAMPUS COMPLIANCE
OF TITLE NINE AND THEIR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT POLICIES, AND ALSO
GIVING CSU A LITTLE MORE TIME TO
SEE THAT IT'S MAKING DECISIONS
BASED ON THE DATA IT COLLECTS
FROM THESE CAMPUSES WITH RESPECT
TO TARGETED OUTREACH AND FURTHER
TRAINING FOR CAMPUSES. SO WITH
THAT, MICHELLE AND I ARE HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU, DR. PARKS, FOR
THE EXCELLENT AUDIT AND THE
REALLY GREAT TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MEMBERS ARE THERE
QUESTIONS FOR MR. PARKS? YES ÁP,
SO THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE.
YOU MENTIONED, WHAT SOUNDS LIKE
REASONABLY GOOD PROGRESS ON THE
REMAINING PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED,
ISSUES. AND THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A
LITTLE BIT SUBJECTIVE, YOU KNOW,
IS YOUR SENSE THAT THE CSU IS
MAKING GOOD PROGRESS? YES I YOU
KNOW, I'VE HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH THE CHANCELLOR. I KNOW OUR
TEAM HAS BEEN IN CONTACT WITH
CSU STAFF. WE FEEL THAT WE'RE
VERY COMFORTABLE THAT CSU IS
TAKING THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
SERIOUSLY AND ARE MAKING
PROGRESS, REALISTIC PROGRESS TO
TRY AND IMPLEMENT THEM. I
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG,
THANK YOU, CHAIR HART. AND THANK
YOU TO THE AUDITORS FOR THE
ROBUST PRESENTATION, SIMILAR
LINE OF QUESTIONING. YOU
MENTIONED SIX RECOMMENDATIONS BY
JULY OF 2026 AND TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS BY JULY OF THIS
YEAR. IN TERMS OF THE PARTIAL
IMPLEMENTATION, DO YOU SEE THAT
THE CSU WILL BE MEETING THESE
RECOMMENDATION DEADLINES? YOU
KNOW, IT'S DIFFICULT TO
FORECAST. I NEVER WANT TO
PROMISE THAT THINGS HAPPEN WHEN
THEY SAY IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
BUT I THINK WE'VE HAD VERY GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CSU, WE
CONTINUE TO BE IN CONTACT WITH
THEM. YOU KNOW, WE'RE NOW AT THE
ONE YEAR MARK. GOING FORWARD,
WE'LL BE CONTINUING TO BE IN
CONTACT WITH THEM ANNUALLY. AND
IT'S NOT JUST THEM PROVIDING
EVIDENCE OF POLICIES THAT
THEY'VE ENACTED FOR THE
REMAINING RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
ARE IN A PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED
OR PENDING STATUS, WE'RE GOING
TO WANT TO SEE EVIDENCE THAT
THOSE POLICIES ARE ACTUALLY
BEING CARRIED OUT IN PRACTICE.
AND SO, MOST IMPORTANTLY, I
THINK FOR ME PERSONALLY, IS I
THINK WE SEE THE POLICIES BEING
ESTABLISHED. BUT I WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO SEE THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE DEMONSTRATING THAT IT'S
CONDUCTING THESE ON SITE CAMPUS
LEVEL MONITORING, REVIEWS OF
TITLE IX AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT
COMPLAINTS, BECAUSE THAT REALLY
GIVES THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND AND TO SEE HOW AND
WHETHER THE CAMPUSES ARE
IMPLEMENTING THEIR POLICIES AND
CONSISTENT CONSISTENTLY, WHETHER
THEY UNDERSTAND THE DIRECTION
THAT'S COMING OUT OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. UNLESS
YOU'RE CONDUCTING MONITORING
REVIEWS OR THERE'S SOME SORT OF
OVERSIGHT, POLICIES BY
THEMSELVES AREN'T GOING TO GET
YOU THERE. SO I THINK THAT'S A
KEY RECOMMENDATION WE MADE, AND
THAT'S ONE THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING CSU IMPLEMENT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CONTEXT. AND
THE UPDATE. AND THEN IN TERMS OF
THE COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
CSU AND THE STATE AUDITOR, ARE
THERE ANY DIFFERING OF OPINIONS
ON THE INTENT OR THE OUTCOME OF
IT ON ANY OF THE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS? DID YOU SEE ANY
DIFFERENCE OF OPINIONS? I DON'T
RECALL US HAVING ANY MAJOR AREAS
OF DISAGREEMENT, OF COURSE, WITH
THE NEW CHANCELLOR COMING IN, IN
MY OPINION, SHE'S BEEN VERY
FORTHRIGHT. IT APPEARS TO ME
THAT SHE WANTS TO IMPROVE THE
CSU AND SHE TAKES OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS VERY SERIOUSLY.
AND I HAVE NO REASON OR BASIS TO
QUESTION THAT. GREAT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR,
SENATOR CORTESE, THANK YOU FOR
THE AUDITOR, TO THE AUDITOR AND
FOR THE AUDITOR IN TERMS OF THE
QUESTION, OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU JUST RECOUNTED IS
UNACCEPTABLE. AND I'M SURE WE'LL
CONTINUE TO HEAR TODAY ABOUT,
REMEDIATION OF THE SITUATION. SO
I'M NOT THE QUESTION IS NOT
INTENDED TO MAKE EXCUSES FOR
ANYBODY, BUT I'M REALLY MORE
CURIOUS, BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE,
WHICH IS NOW GOING ON, GOING ON
FIVE YEARS OLD AS A SANTA CLARA
COUNTY SUPERVISOR, WHERE WE
STEPPED IN WITH THE PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES IN OUR AREA, TO SET
UP OVERSIGHT, WHICH IS REALLY A
STRETCH OF COURSE, FOR A COUNTY
ON TITLE NINE, BUT WE FELT LIKE
SOMEBODY NEEDED TO COME IN AND
PUT ANOTHER SET OF EYES ON WHAT
WAS GOING ON BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLAINTS, YOU KNOW, THE AMOUNT
OF PUBLIC COMMENT WE WERE
GETTING AND WHAT WE FOUND IS AT
LEAST SOME OF THAT WAS
DERIVATIVE OF, YOU KNOW, CHANGES
IN TITLE NINE THAT HAD OCCURRED,
PARTICULARLY POST THE TRUMP
ELECTION. AND THEN JUST
ADMINISTRATIVE, FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGES THAT WERE
MADE THAT THAT THE UNIVERSITIES
WERE, OSTENSIBLY HAVING TROUBLE
KEEPING UP WITH. DID YOU SEE ANY
SIGN OF THAT IN YOUR WORK? AND
AGAIN, IT'S NOT TO MAKE EXCUSES
FOR ANYONE. THESE ARE PRETTY
CLEAR CUT, YOU KNOW, MEASURES
THAT TITLE NINE IS ALWAYS BLACK
LETTER LAW. IT'S CLEAR CUT. I
UNDERSTAND THAT, AND WHAT YOU'RE
SUGGESTING IS PRETTY CLEAR CUT,
BUT I'M JUST TRYING TO GET A
FEEL FOR THE LARGER PICTURE. AND
IF YOU SAW ANY OF THAT IN YOUR
WORK, I MAY HAVE TO DEFER TO
MICHELLE ON THAT. BUT, YOU KNOW,
MY RECOLLECTION IS I DON'T
REMEMBER THAT BEING A DRIVING
FACTOR FOR THE CONDITIONS THAT
WE SAW, I THINK WHAT WE
PRIMARILY SAW IS WHEN WE WERE
LOOKING AT THESE ALLEGATIONS AND
WE WERE SEEING THE NATURE OF THE
ALLEGATIONS, WHICH TO US AS A
LAYPERSON SEEMED PRETTY
EGREGIOUS IN SOME CASES. AND
THEN CSU INVESTIGATORS DECIDING
THIS WASN'T WORTH THE EFFORT TO
INVESTIGATE BECAUSE IT WASN'T A
VIOLATION OF CSU POLICY THAT
CREATED A DISCONNECT FOR US. AND
SO I THINK THAT'S PRIMARILY WHAT
WE SAW. AND TO ME, THAT SPEAKS
TO A NEED OF GREATER
CONSISTENCY, GREATER TRAINING,
GREATER MESSAGING FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN TERMS OF
WHAT EXPECTATIONS SHOULD BE FOR
TITLE NINE STAFF AT THE CAMPUS
LEVEL. BUT MICHELLE, DID YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON TITLE NINE
CHANGES AND IMPACT? SURE THANK
YOU, CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. JUST FOR THE RECORD,
MY NAME IS MICHELLE SANDERS,
PRINCIPAL AUDITOR WITH THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE. SO JUST
SOMETHING TO NOTE. WE EXAMINED
CSU'S POLICY PRIMARILY IN DOING
THIS AUDIT, BECAUSE IT IS A MORE
STRINGENT STANDARD THAN THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS THAT ARE
GOING ON. IF THERE ARE ANY
CHANGES IN THAT SORT OF THING.
SO OUR RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD
STILL BE APPLICABLE TO, YOU
KNOW, CHANGES TO THE POLICY, TO
THE GUIDANCE, BECAUSE ALL OF
THAT'S STILL MORE STRINGENT. SO
EVEN IF THERE ARE CHANGES AND
THEY'RE TRYING TO KEEP UP WITH
THEM, THEIR POLICY IS REALLY THE
MAIN DRIVER TO MAKING SURE THAT
GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
PROTECTING THE STUDENTS,
EMPLOYEES, THAT'S GREAT. GREAT
ANSWER. YOU KNOW, IN TERMS OF
ANSWERING MY QUESTION, THAT
CLEARS THAT UP FOR ME. I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S FAIR TO ASK, YOU
KNOW, A QUESTION. I DON'T MEAN
TO PRESENT A HYPOTHETICAL AT
ALL, BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE MAY BE ROOM FOR
LEGISLATION. FOR WHAT I'M GOING
TO ASK NEXT. AND THAT IS, AS I
AS I NOTED, MY HOME COUNTY, WHEN
I WAS THERE AS A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, JUST TOOK
ITS OWN INITIATIVE TO SET UP AS
MUCH OF AN OVERSIGHT MECHANISM
AS IT COULD WITH ITS OWN, WITH
ITS PUBLIC HEARING PROCESS AND
SO FORTH, AND, YOU KNOW, THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING TO MY KNOWLEDGE,
THAT'S THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS CERTAINLY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HASN'T
AUTHORIZED OR SET UP ANYTHING
LIKE THAT. BUT TO THE EXTENT
THAT LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL MIGHT
SAY THAT WE COULD ESTABLISH
STATUTE THAT WOULD GIVE THE 58
COUNTIES AT LEAST THE RIGHT TO
COME IN AND DO THE KIND OF
OVERSIGHT THAT OBVIOUSLY, YOU WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE. YOU DO,
YOU KNOW, EVERY YEAR, WHAT DO
YOU THINK OF THAT IDEA? IS IT
AGAIN ASSUMING IT HAS, YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE THE LEGAL STANDING TO DO
IT. IS IT? I'M REALLY ASKING
ABOUT THE NECESSITY OF IT. IS IT
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY
SHOULD HAVE CHECKS AND BALANCES
ON? AND ANOTHER, ANOTHER SET OF
EYES? WELL, I'LL BE CAREFUL TO,
TO LIMIT MY COMMENTS TO WHAT WE
TALK ABOUT IN THE AUDIT REPORT,
BUT I WILL SAY GENERALLY,
CLEARLY SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS A
VERY SERIOUS ISSUE AND NEEDS TO
BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY, WHETHER IT'S
AT A UNIVERSITY CAMPUS, WHETHER
IT'S AT A LOCAL GOVERNMENT,
WHETHER IT'S ANYWHERE. AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
FINDS THAT THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
TOOLS AND OVERSIGHT MECHANISMS,
YOU CAN ADVOCATE AND AUTHORIZE
FOR UNIVERSITIES OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, THAT'S JUST ONE
MORE TOOL TO PUT IN THE TOOLBOX.
ASSUMING THE RESOURCES ARE THERE
TO FUND IT AND TO MAKE IT A REAL
OVERSIGHT PROCESS. I THINK IN
THE AREA OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT,
MORE OVERSIGHT, MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY IS DEFINITELY A
GOOD THING. YEAH. I MEAN, I
MEAN, CLEARLY, GIVEN THE WAY
THINGS WORK HERE, BUDGETARY AND
APPROPRIATIONS WISE AND
EVERYTHING, IT WOULD PROBABLY
HAVE TO BE AN OPT IN, A
PERMISSIVE KIND OF A STATUTE
THAT A COUNTY COULD DO IT. BUT
IT WAS MY RECOLLECTION THAT A
LOT OF THE PUSHBACK THAT WE GOT
FOR DOING SOMETHING THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE SEEM TO BE, YOU KNOW,
HELPFUL AND COMMON SENSE TO, TO
STEP IN AND HOLD HEARINGS AND
GATHER EVIDENCE, YOU KNOW, THE
PUSHBACK WAS, DO YOU REALLY HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO DO THAT, YOU
KNOW, AS A COUNTY. SO IT'S THE
ONLY REASON I'M PROBING A LITTLE
BIT, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR RESPONSES. AND THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU, SENATOR
CORTESE. SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU TO THE
AUDITOR, I WAS WORKING ON SOME
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR, 1491,
THAT WOULD ASK, THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND THE CSU TO HAVE A
DESIGNATED POINT PERSON FOR
LGBTQ ISSUES AND COMPLAINTS AS
THEY COME IN. THAT REQUIREMENT
WAS MADE. I THINK, A DECADE AGO,
BUT IT'S NEVER REALLY BEEN
INSTITUTED ALL THE WAY. AND
WE'RE ALSO ASKING THAT IT BE A
CONFIDENTIAL PERSON, ANY ANY
ISSUES THAT YOU SAW AROUND LGBTQ
ISSUES ON CAMPUSES. AND AS IT'S
RELATED TO REPORT OF RETALIATION
AND HARASSMENT, DID YOU SEE
ANYTHING IN OUR EVALUATION OF
THE 40 CASE FILES? THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT CAME UP, THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT IT'S NOT A
CONCERN AND THAT THIS ISN'T
REALLY IMPORTANT, BUT THAT'S
JUST NOT SOMETHING THAT WE SAW
IN THE 40 CASE FILES WE
REVIEWED. OKAY I DO RECALL THAT
WE DID SEE EXAMPLES IN OUR, IN
OUR CASES THAT IT'S, YOU KNOW,
WHEN YOU THINK OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT, YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES
THE COMMON THOUGHT IS IT'S A
MALE HARASSING A FEMALE. I
BELIEVE WE DID SEE INSTANCES
WHERE IT WAS MALES HARASSING
MALES. SO IT'S NOT JUST, YOU
KNOW, TYPICALLY HOW YOU VIEW
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. WE DID SEE IT
ACROSS YOU KNOW, ALL ALL, ALL
SIDES OF SOCIETY. AND ANY
DIFFERENCE ON REPORTING OR
HANDLING OF THOSE SITUATIONS.
NO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR EGGMAN. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS? I HAVE A
QUESTION. ONE OF THE MOST
TROUBLING THINGS ABOUT YOUR
REPORT IS THE FACT THAT THIS IS
NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT THIS HAS
HAPPENED, THAT THIS HAS BEEN
GOING BACK TO 2014. YOUR OFFICE
RECOMMENDED THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CONDUCT
ROUTINE REVIEWS AND THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE ACCEPTED.
AND THE CSU CAMPUSES WERE DOING
THOSE REVIEWS FROM 2015 TO 2018.
AND THEN, THEY HAVE THEY STOPPED
AT A CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME. AND
YOU AGAIN, HAVE MADE THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND I KNOW WE
HAVE NEW LEADERSHIP AT CSU, AND
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY FORTHCOMING
AND AGREEING TO CORRECT THOSE
ISSUES AND ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC
ISSUES. BUT, YOU KNOW, WHAT
GIVES YOU REASON TO THINK THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE IN THE
SAME PLACE, YOU KNOW, FIVE YEARS
FROM NOW WITH THE REPETITIVE
SYSTEMIC PROBLEM? IS THERE
SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK IS
DIFFERENT THIS TIME AROUND THAT
GIVES YOU MORE ENCOURAGEMENT
ABOUT THIS? IS GOING TO WORK
THIS TIME? WELL, I WASN'T
INVOLVED WITH THE PRIOR AUDIT,
BUT FROM MY LIMITED
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CHANCELLOR AND THE NEW STAFF,
THERE SEEMS TO BE A LEVEL OF
COMMITMENT TO IMPLEMENTING OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS, WHICH I FIND TO
BE HOPEFUL. WHEN THE CSU DECIDED
TO STOP DOING ITS MONITORING
REVIEWS, I REMEMBER, OR I SEEM
TO RECALL. AND MICHELLE, YOU CAN
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG, THAT
THE EXPLANATION WE GOT WAS WE
HAVE CHANGING LEADERSHIP. WE
HAVE CHANGING FUNDING
PRIORITIES, OTHER ISSUES COME
UP. I THINK, TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE HAVE LEGISLATION, I BELIEVE
SUCH AS YOUR BILL THAT WOULD
ALLOW, CONTINUING MONITORING BY
THE STATE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED. AND FURTHER, THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A STATE LAW
THAT NOW REQUIRES CSU TO
IMPLEMENT OUR RECOMMENDATIONS. I
THINK THEIR LEVEL OF DISCRETION
TO IMPLEMENT A RECOMMENDATION
ONE DAY AND THEN STOP DOING IT
ANOTHER DAY, I WOULDN'T SAY THE
RISK IS ZERO, BUT THE RISK IS
LESS NOW. AND SO I THINK THAT
THAT'S THAT'S A POSITIVE
DEVELOPMENT THAT DIDN'T EXIST
BEFORE. THANK YOU. I AGREE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE LEGISLATION IN PLACE THAT
WILL ENSURE THE ACCOUNTABILITY
AS TIME GOES AND LEADERSHIP
CHANGES OCCUR IN THE FUTURE,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN YEAH.
SO JUST LISTENING TO THE REPORT,
I HAVE TO SAY A LOT OF IT IS
REALLY SHOCKING AND AWFUL. I YOU
KNOW, WHEN I SAW THE REPORT, I
WAS SURPRISED AT THIS DATE,
GIVEN THE FOCUS ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OVER THE YEARS AND
ALSO ON THE VERY CLEAR, POWER
IMBALANCES AND AGE IMBALANCES
THAT MAKE THE POPULATION AT OUR
UNIVERSITIES, PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO HARASSMENT AND
ASSAULT, THAT IT JUST SEEMS THAT
WE ARE JUST MIRED IN THIS
CULTURE THAT IS, FOR WHATEVER
REASON, KIND OF REFUSING TO
CHANGE. AND I GUESS I'M JUST
WONDERING, WHETHER YOU FEEL THAT
THE CAMPUSES HAVE A REAL
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW OF THE
SCOPE OF THE ISSUE AND AN
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW TO CHANGE
WHATEVER THE CULTURE IS THERE,
THAT IS JUST SORT OF ALLOWING
THIS TO CONTINUALLY HAPPEN, YOU
KNOW, DO YOU GET THE SENSE
THROUGH YOUR CONVERSATIONS THAT,
YOU KNOW, WHETHER THERE'S I
MEAN, CERTAINLY I HAVE NO DOUBT
THAT THERE'S A DESIRE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FIX THIS, BUT
DO YOU GET THE SENSE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND HOW TO FIX IT BEYOND
IMPLEMENTING WHAT YOU'VE PUT ON
PAPER? BECAUSE IT'S ONE THING TO
HAVE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS. IT'S
ANOTHER THING TO REALLY COMMIT
TO THE KIND OF SERIOUS CULTURE
CHANGE YOU NEED TO, TO ADDRESS
THIS. BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, WE KNOW
FROM WHEN WE WENT THROUGH THIS,
YOU KNOW, HERE AND THE CONTINUAL
EFFORTS THAT WE HAVE WITH OUR
OWN CLIMATE, THAT IT'S NOT THE
CASE, THAT PUTTING A RULE ON
PAPER IS GOING TO CHANGE
ANYTHING? WELL, I THINK A CHANGE
IN CULTURE ALWAYS STARTS WITH
THE TONE AT THE TOP OF THE
ORGANIZATION, AND THEN IT NEEDS
TO BE FOLLOWED UP WITH
MONITORING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT TONE AND THAT MESSAGING IS
FILTERING DOWN TO THE PEOPLE
THAT ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THE
POLICY, TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT CAMPUSES
CONSISTENTLY GET IT, I WOULD SAY
DURING THE PERIOD OF OUR AUDIT
WHEN WE WERE LOOKING AT THE
DECISIONS THAT WERE BEING MADE
ABOUT WHETHER TO INVESTIGATE OR
NOT INVESTIGATE, I WOULD SAY THE
ANSWER WAS NO, CLEARLY THAT
THERE WERE ALLEGATIONS THAT WERE
BEING BROUGHT BY CSU STUDENTS OR
OTHER CSU FACULTY THAT RAISED
SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY SOME
OF THESE ALLEGATIONS WEREN'T
WORTHY OF AN INVESTIGATION AND
PURSUING THE MATTER FURTHER, BUT
I THINK CULTURE CHANGES WHEN
EXPECTATIONS ARE CLEAR. BUT TO
YOUR POINT, IT'S NOT JUST CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS. IT'S MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS ONGOING MONITORING
BY THOSE WHO ARE SETTING POLICY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S FOLLOW
UP AND THAT THERE'S CONSISTENCY
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
POLICIES. WE CAN AUDIT, WE CAN
PROVIDE TO CSU, CAN PROVIDE
TRAININGS. BUT I THINK IT'S
GOING TO TAKE TIME AND IT'S
GOING TO TAKE REPETITION, AND
IT'S GOING TO TAKE FEEDBACK FROM
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE STAFF THAT ARE
DOING THE WORK ARE GETTING THE
MESSAGE. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN, ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE? WELL, THANK YOU,
AUDITOR PARKS AND MISS SANDERS
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
INFORMATION TODAY. THANK YOU.
NEXT, WE'LL HAVE THE SECOND
PANEL, WHICH IS CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. CHANCELLOR GARCIA.
WELCOME. CHANCELLOR GARCIA, MISS
SCHWARZKOPF, I MAY I MAY BEGIN.
YES, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
HART FONG AND NEWMAN, THANK YOU
FOR HOLDING TODAY'S HEARING. AND
FOR PROVIDING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE PART IN IT. I AM DOCTOR
MILDRED GARCIA, CHANCELLOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
WITH ME TODAY IS THE ASSOCIATE
VICE CHANCELLOR OF THE CSU'S
NEWLY ESTABLISHED OFFICE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS, PROGRAMING AND
SERVICES. HALEY SCHWARZKOPF. I
WANT TO BEGIN BY ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT FOR TOO LONG, THE CSU HAS
FALLEN SHORT IN OUR EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR UNIVERSITIES ARE
SAFE AND WELCOMING ENVIRONMENTS
WHERE STUDENTS, FACULTY AND
STAFF CAN THRIVE PERSONALLY,
PROFESSIONALLY AND
INTELLECTUALLY FREE OF
DISCRIMINATION, HARASSMENT AND
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT. OUR ACTIONS
AND INACTIONS RELATED TO TITLE
NINE HAVE HARMED OUR STUDENTS,
STAFF, AND FACULTY. WE HAVE
HEARD IT FROM MEMBERS OF THE CSU
COMMUNITY ACROSS THE SYSTEM. WE
HAVE LET THEM DOWN AS WE HAVE
LET YOU, DOWN TO ALL OF THEM AND
TO YOU. I SAY WE ARE DEEPLY
SORRY. DISCRIMINATION AND
HARASSMENT HAS NO PLACE AT THE
CSU, AND I AM COMMITTED TO
ENSURING WE LEARN FROM OUR
MISTAKES SO THAT WE MAY NEVER
REPEAT THEM, AND SO THAT WE CAN
TURN WEAKNESSES INTO STRENGTHS.
THE WORK WE ARE ENGAGED IN
REQUIRES NOTHING SHORT OF
CULTURAL CHANGE. OF COURSE, WE
MUST STRENGTHEN OUR CULTURE OF
COMPLIANCE. OUR PROCESSES MUST
NOT BE OVERLY COMPLEX OR
LEGALISTIC, BUT RATHER EASY TO
ACCESS, SUPPORTIVE, RESPECTFUL,
AND COMPASSIONATE THROUGHOUT.
AND THEY MUST RESULT IN PROMPT
AND FAIR AND MEANINGFUL
RESOLUTIONS. BUT WE MUST ALSO
BUILD AND MAINTAIN A CULTURE OF
CARE. THAT MEANS ONGOING
PREVENTION PROGRAMS, AWARENESS
CAMPAIGNS, AND BYSTANDER
EDUCATION. AND IT MEANS HONORING
AND LIVING OUT OUR CORE VALUES
SO THAT OUR UNIVERSITIES ARE
PLACES WHERE EVERY PERSON IS
RESPECTED, PROTECTED, AND
EMPOWERED TO PURSUE THEIR GOALS
FREE FROM ANY HARASSING OR
DISCRIMINATORY BEHAVIORS. IT HAS
BEEN ONE YEAR SINCE THE CSU
RECEIVED COMPREHENSIVE REPORTS
FROM BOTH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR AND THE LAW FIRM COZEN
O'CONNOR REGARDING OUR CIVIL
RIGHTS PROGRAM AND SERVICES.
BOTH OF THOSE REPORTS SET FORTH
DETAILED RECOMMENDATIONS AND
TIMELINES TO INFORM OUR WORK TO
STRENGTHEN OUR SYSTEMS OF
COMPLIANCE AND OF CARE.
IMPLEMENTING THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS HAS BEEN A TOP
PRIORITY OF MINE SINCE I BECAME
CHANCELLOR TEN MONTHS AGO. ON
OCTOBER FIRST. TO THIS END, I
HAVE DIRECTED $15.9 MILLION TO
BE INVESTED ACROSS OUR
UNIVERSITIES TO BOLSTER OUR
TITLE NINE PRACTICES. THIS
ACADEMIC YEAR, I CAN REPORT THAT
THE CSU HAS SUBMITTED PROOF OF
COMPLETION OF THE YEAR ONE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR, MANY OF WHICH ARE
ALIGNED WITH THOSE MADE BY COZEN
O'CONNOR RELATED TO THE
POLICIES, PROCEDURES AND
OVERSIGHT OF OUR CIVIL RIGHTS
PROGRAMING. 12 RECOMMENDATIONS
HAD A SUGGESTED COMPLETION DATE
OF JULY 2024. WE ARE PLEASED TO
HAVE RECEIVED AGREEMENT FROM THE
STATE AUDITOR THAT TEN OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED, AND TWO ARE
PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED. IN THE
TWO CASES OF PARTIAL COMPLETION
COMPLETION, WE HAVE CREATED THE
PROCESSES THAT WERE REQUIRED.
HOWEVER, AS YOU HEARD, THE STATE
AUDITOR HAS ASKED TO SEE THOSE
PROCESSES IN ACTION AT THE
UNIVERSITY LEVEL BEFORE THEY
CONSIDER THOSE TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS FULLY COMPLETE
THE NEW AND STRENGTHENED
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTED ARE CRITICAL,
CONCRETE IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE
THE RESULT OF SIGNIFICANT EFFORT
BY THE ENTIRE CSU COMMUNITY,
FROM OUR BOARD OF TRUSTEES TO
OUR FACULTY AND STAFF, AND TO
OUR STUDENTS, ASSOCIATE VICE
CHANCELLOR SCHWARZKOPF AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSING OUR
PROGRESS WITH YOU TODAY. AS WELL
AS THE WORK, THE WORK THAT LIES
BEFORE US. BUT FIRST, I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE CSU IS
COMMITTED TO GOING BEYOND THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS. WE
ARE TAKING A COMPREHENSIVE,
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO OUR TITLE
NINE AND CIVIL RIGHTS PROGRAMS,
ONE THAT IS CENTERED ON OUR
STUDENTS, STAFF AND FACULTY.
FURTHER, WE ARE COMMITTED TO
PROGRAMS THAT PRIORITIZE
PREVENTION. TO THIS END, WE ARE
CONSTANTLY COMMUNICATING OUR
VALUES AND EXPECTATIONS,
TRAINING OUR STUDENT STAFF AND
FACULTY, AND KEEPING OUR
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION, HARASSMENT,
RETALIATION, AND OTHER CONDUCT
OF CONCERN FRONT AND CENTER IN
THE WORK OF OUR SYSTEM AND OUR
23 UNIVERSITIES. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO MODELING WHAT A
CARING, SUPPORTIVE, AND
EQUITABLE COMMUNITY LOOKS LIKE.
AS NOTED BY THE STATE AUDITOR,
THERE IS STILL MUCH WORK TO BE
DONE. WE ARE COMMITTED TO THIS
WORK AND WE WILL MEET OR EXCEED
OUR DEADLINES, BUT SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE
SPECIFICALLY IN THE PAST YEAR,
WE HAVE CREATED A SYSTEM WIDE
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS
PROGRAMING AND SERVICES TO
PROVIDE CENTRALIZED PLANNING,
OVERSIGHT, SUPPORT AND RESOURCES
TO THE CSU CAMPUS LEVEL TITLE
NINE AND DR. OFFICES WITH A
FOCUS ON TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
AND FAIR PROCESSES. THIS
INCLUDES THE CREATION OF FIVE
SYSTEM WIDE DIRECTOR POSITIONS
AND THE ADDITION OF FIVE CIVIL
RIGHTS ATTORNEYS IN THE OFFICE
OF GENERAL COUNSEL, WHO WILL
WORK WITH OUR UNIVERSITY
PARTNERS IN A REGIONAL MODEL ON
A DAY TO DAY BASIS. WE HAVE GONE
FROM A TOTAL OF FIVE MEMBERS
CONDUCTING THIS WORK AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO 15 WHO
WILL BE PROVIDING DIRECT SUPPORT
TO OUR 23 UNIVERSITIES. I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE AN
ORGANIZATIONAL CHART IN FRONT OF
YOU. IN RESPONSE TO THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS. WE
NOW REQUIRE ALL UNIVERSITIES TO
TRACK KEY DATES AND TIMELINE
EXTENSIONS IN A CONSISTENT
MANNER, INCLUDING DEVELOPING A
SYSTEM FOR REMINDERS AND FOLLOW
UP TO IMPROVE THE TIMELINESS OF
INVESTIGATIONS. WE REQUIRE
CRITICAL DOCUMENTS TO BE
MAINTAINED IN THE CASE FILE
BEFORE CLOSING THE CASE,
INCLUDING DOCUMENTATION OF THE
UNIVERSITY'S INITIAL ASSESSMENT
OF THE ALLEGATIONS AND ITS
RATIONALE FOR WHETHER OR NOT TO
CONDUCT AN INVESTIGATION. SYSTEM
WIDE, WE HAVE ADOPTED NEW
POLICIES REGARDING RETREAT
RIGHTS AND EMPLOYMENT
REFERENCES, SO THEY DO NOT
BENEFIT THOSE EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE
ENGAGED IN IMPROPER ACTIVITY.
AND WE HAVE FULLY REVISED THE
CSU'S NONDISCRIMINATION POLICY
BASED UPON FEEDBACK FROM THE
STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS THE SYSTEM,
THE NONDISCRIMINATION POLICY
BECAME EFFECTIVE AUGUST 1ST. IT
ADDRESSES A RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE STATE AUDITOR AND ALIGNS
WITH THE LEGISLATION IN THE
ASSEMBLY'S TITLE NINE PACKAGE. I
UNDERSTAND THAT MUCH OF THIS
WORK MAY SEEM HEAVY ON PROCESS
REORGANIZING STAFF, REVISING
POLICIES, ISSUING GUIDELINES,
BUILDING NEW TRACKING SYSTEMS,
ETC. INDEED, WE ARE BUILDING NEW
AND BETTER INFRASTRUCTURE, BUT
THIS NEW INFRASTRUCTURE IS WHAT
IS NEEDED TO CREATE A MORE
CONSISTENT, RESPONSIBLE AND
RELIABLE SYSTEM, ONE THAT WORKS
PROPERLY WHEN OUR STUDENTS,
STAFF AND FACULTY NEED IT TO. AS
I HAVE NOTED, WE STILL HAVE A
GREAT DEAL OF WORK AHEAD OF US,
BUT WE ARE ON TRACK TO MEET ALL
OF OUR DEADLINES IN 2025 AND
2026, AND WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
MOMENTUM AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND AS WE HONOR OUR
COMMITMENT TO ACCOUNTABILITY, WE
WILL CONDUCT REGULAR PROGRAM
REVIEWS OF THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND THE TITLE NINE HR
OFFICES FOR EACH UNIVERSITY
CAMPUS. AT LEAST ONCE EVERY
THREE YEARS. TO ENSURE THAT OUR
POLICIES AND PROCESSES ARE
EFFECTIVE, THIS FIRST SET OF
PROGRAM REVIEWS WILL BEGIN THIS
FALL. BEFORE I CLOSE, I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE AGAIN THAT THIS WORK
IS NOT ABOUT MERE COMPLIANCE.
IT'S NOT ONLY ABOUT CHECKING
BOXES. THIS IS ABOUT
TRANSFORMATIVE, SUSTAINABLE
CULTURAL CHANGE. AND THAT MEANS
TRANSPARENTLY MONITORING AND
MEASURING OUR RESULTS IN A
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT. AS WE STRENGTHEN
OUR CULTURES OF CARE AND
COMPLIANCE, AND TO ULTIMATELY
REALIZING OUR VISION TO SERVE AS
A NATIONAL MODEL IN PROTECTING
AND SUPPORTING OUR UNIVERSITY
COMMUNITIES. AS THE NATION'S
LARGEST, MOST DIVERSE, AND MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. IT IS OUR
MORAL IMPERATIVE. OUR STUDENTS,
FACULTY, AND STAFF INDEED ALL
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND
STAKEHOLDERS, DEMAND IT. YOU
RIGHTFULLY DEMAND IT, AND THE
CSU'S MISSION AND CORE VALUES
REQUIRE IT. AGAIN I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY. NOW, I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE ASSOCIATE VICE CHANCELLOR
SCHWARZKOPF SHARE FURTHER
DETAILS ABOUT THE WORK THAT IS
BEING DONE SYSTEMWIDE AT EACH OF
THE CSU'S 23 UNIVERSITIES. THANK
YOU, CHANCELLOR GARCIA, TO THE
CHAIRS AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES HERE TODAY. I WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE STRUCTURE
OF THE SYSTEMWIDE OFFICE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS, PROGRAMING AND
SERVICES AT THE CSU CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND THE WORK THAT WE HAVE
BEEN DOING. MY NAME IS HAILEY
SCHWARZKOPF, AND I'M THE
ASSOCIATE VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS, PROGRAMING AND
SERVICES WITH THE CSU. I HAVE
SPENT MY ENTIRE PROFESSIONAL
CAREER AS A CIVIL RIGHTS
PRACTITIONER. BEFORE I WAS HIRED
AT THE CSU SIX MONTHS AGO, I
SERVED AS A TITLE NINE
COORDINATOR AND DHR
ADMINISTRATOR ON A COLLEGE
CAMPUS FOR OVER SEVEN YEARS.
BEFORE THAT, I SERVED AS AN AS A
LITIGATOR REPRESENTING EMPLOYEES
AND EMPLOYERS IN CASES INVOLVING
DISCRIMINATION, HARASSMENT,
RETALIATION, WHISTLEBLOWING AND
OTHER CIVIL RIGHTS CASES. I KNOW
FIRSTHAND THE CHALLENGES OF THIS
WORK AND THE IMPACTS THAT THESE
CASES HAVE ON OUR STUDENTS,
EMPLOYEES, AND GREATER CAMPUS
COMMUNITY. FOLLOWING THE
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR AND THE
INTERNAL ASSESSMENT CONDUCTED BY
COZEN O'CONNOR IN 2023, THE CSU
HAS INVESTED SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES TO CREATE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE
ACROSS THE CSU'S 23 UNIVERSITY
CAMPUS SYSTEM. IN FRONT OF YOU
IS A COPY OF AN ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURE OF OUR SYSTEMWIDE
OFFICE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS
PROGRAMING AND SERVICES. THIS
STRUCTURE MOVES THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AWAY FROM PROVIDING ONLY
ADVICE AND CONSULTATION TO OUR
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES. WHEN
REQUESTED TO A TRUE LEADERSHIP
AND OVERSIGHT MODEL THAT HAS
BEEN ENVISIONED BY THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY. THE STATE
AUDITOR, OUR CHANCELLOR, AND THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES. AS NOTED BY
CHANCELLOR GARCIA, THE
SYSTEMWIDE OFFICE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS EXPANDED FROM A TEAM OF 5
TO 15 EMPLOYEES TO SUPPORT THIS
WORK AND ENSURE CONSISTENCY,
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN AN ONGOING MANNER. WHILE
THERE ARE MANY POSITIONS THAT
ARE REPRESENTED ON THIS
ORGANIZATIONAL CHART, IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME, I'M GOING TO
SPECIFICALLY FOCUS ON A FEW.
TODAY. I'D LIKE TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE GREEN BOXES.
THE FIVE BOXES ON THE RIGHT
REPRESENT OUR SYSTEMWIDE
DIRECTORS, EACH SYSTEMWIDE
DIRECTOR IS ASSIGNED 4 TO 5
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES THAT THEY
SUPPORT. IN A REGIONAL MODEL
THAT I WILL SHARE WITH YOU
MOMENTARILY. THE SYSTEMWIDE
DIRECTORS ARE IN DAILY AND
WEEKLY CONTACT WITH THE CIVIL
RIGHTS OFFICES ON THEIR ASSIGNED
CAMPUSES. WHAT'S NOT REFLECTED
ARE THE FIVE CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEYS WHO ARE PARTNERED WITH
EACH OF OUR SYSTEMWIDE DIRECTORS
TO SUPPORT THEIR UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES ON THAT DAY TO DAY
BASIS, THE SYSTEMWIDE DIRECTORS
MEET WEEKLY TOGETHER TO ENSURE
CONSISTENCY, AND THEY ALSO MEET
WEEKLY WITH THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEYS TO ENSURE CONSISTENCY
IN THEIR OVERSIGHT OF CASES.
BEST PRACTICES AND THE SUPPORT
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING TO OUR
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES. THERE ARE
TWO OTHER SYSTEMWIDE DIRECTORS
ON THE LEFT HAND SIDE. THE FIRST
IS OUR SYSTEM WIDE DIRECTOR FOR
PREVENTION, EDUCATION AND
TRAINING. YOU HEARD THE
CHANCELLOR SPEAK ABOUT OUR WORK
IN PREVENTION AND HOW TO CLEARLY
COMMUTE OUR COMMUNICATE OUR
EXPECTATIONS TO OUR CAMPUS
COMMUNITIES. SUE MCCARTHY
RECENTLY TRANSITIONED TO THIS
ROLE IN JUNE, AND SHE IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR SUPPORTING
PREVENTION, EDUCATION AND
TRAINING FOR STUDENTS AND
EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE CSU SYSTEM.
SHE WILL WORK COLLABORATIVELY
WITH THE CAMPUS PREVENTION
EDUCATION TEAMS TO CREATE
AWARENESS, EVENTS AND PREVENTION
PROGRAMING. SHE IS ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR CREATING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR CIVIL
RIGHTS PRACTITIONERS. FOR
EXAMPLE, THAT INCLUDED OUR
ANNUAL CIVIL RIGHTS CONFERENCE
THAT WE JUST HELD AT THE END OF
JULY THROUGH REGULAR WORKSHOPS
AND OTHER SERIES. THIS YEAR'S
CONFERENCE WAS HEAVILY FOCUSED
ON THE GUIDANCE THAT WE HAVE
ISSUED OVER THE LAST YEAR.
AGAIN, TO ENSURE THAT
CONSISTENCY AND APPLICATION.
ANOTHER SYSTEM WIDE DIRECTOR
POSITION SUPPORTS INVESTIGATIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. LARA KANSEN IS
THE EMPLOYEE WHO HAS BEEN
SELECTED FOR THIS ROLE. SHE'S
CURRENTLY SERVING IN AN INTERIM
CAPACITY TO SUPPORT OUR
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES WHILE WE
HIRE THE FIFTH AND FINAL SYSTEM
WIDE DIRECTOR. AND WHEN SHE
TRANSITIONS TO THIS NEW ROLE,
SHE WILL HELP SUPPORT THE
OVERSIGHT OF ALL OF OUR
INVESTIGATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
CSU SYSTEM. THAT INCLUDES
INVESTIGATIONS INVOLVING HIGH
LEVEL ADMINISTRATORS OR OTHER,
CAMPUS TITLE NINE COORDINATORS.
WE ARE ALSO WORKING ON A SYSTEM
WIDE APPROACH TO INVESTIGATIONS,
INCLUDING THE CREATION OF A
SYSTEM WIDE NETWORK OF
INVESTIGATORS WHO WILL SUPPORT
OUR UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES AS
NEEDED. FINALLY, I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE TEAM MEMBER IN THE
YELLOW BOX, MARIANNE LOWE IS
OUR, THE EMPLOYEE WHO HAS BEEN
DESIGNATED TO SUPPORT OUR
UNIFIED CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
THAT WILL BE FORTHCOMING. SHE IS
OUR DATA INTEGRATION PARTNER AND
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR COLLECTING
AND ANALYZING THE DATA FROM OUR
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE UNDER SB
808. THAT WENT INTO EFFECT ON
JANUARY THE 1ST, THE CSU WILL
PROVIDE A REPORT TO THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY ON DECEMBER
1ST. THAT REPORT INCLUDES THINGS
SUCH AS THE TIMELINESS OF
COMPLETION, THE NUMBER OF CASES,
OUR ANNUAL SURVEY TO COLLECT
THIS INFORMATION FROM OUR
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES IS UNDERWAY,
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO SHARING
THAT REPORT WITH YOU. THIS MODEL
REPRESENTS MORE THAN JUST A
STRUCTURAL SHIFT. IT IS A
CULTURAL SHIFT IN A WAY THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS WORKING
WITH OUR CAMPUS PARTNERS AND
OVERSEEING THIS WORK. THIS IS
REPRESENTED IN THE SECOND CHART
THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE REFLECTING
OUR REGIONAL LEADERSHIP AND
OVERSIGHT MODEL. EACH CAMPUS,
INCLUDING THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE, IS DIVIDED INTO ONE OF
FIVE REGIONS. EACH REGION IS
SUPPORTED BY A SYSTEM WIDE
DIRECTOR AND A CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY. THIS MEANS THAT EVERY
CAMPUS HAS THEIR OWN CIVIL
RIGHTS STAFF, AND ADDITIONAL
LAYERS OF SUPPORT THROUGH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE, WITH THE
SYSTEM WIDE DIRECTOR AND CIVIL
RIGHTS ATTORNEY, THIS IS A LEVEL
OF SUPPORT AND OVERSIGHT THAT
HAS NEVER EXISTED WITHIN THE CSU
SYSTEM BEFORE. THE CSU RECENTLY
TRANSITIONED TO THIS REGIONAL
OVERSIGHT MODEL IN JUNE. WHILE
IT IS STILL NEW, WE ARE ALREADY
STARTING TO SEE THE BENEFITS OF
THIS STRUCTURE. OUR SYSTEM WIDE
DIRECTORS ARE HOLDING OFFICE
HOURS WITH THEIR ENTIRE REGION
AND BUILDING THAT RAPPORT AND
SYNERGY BETWEEN OUR UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES. EACH REGION MEETS
REGULARLY TO BUILD THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS, SHARE CHALLENGES,
BEST PRACTICES, GO THROUGH CASE
STUDIES AND CONDUCT TRAINING.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS
ENSURING THAT OUR GUIDANCE IS
BEING IMPLEMENTED IN A
CONSISTENT WAY. WE ALSO HOLD
MONTHLY MEETINGS WITH ALL OF OUR
CIVIL RIGHTS PRACTITIONERS
ACROSS THE SYSTEM. AGAIN, TO
ENSURE THAT CONSISTENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS MODEL
ALIGNS WITH OUR FOCUS ON TRAUMA
INFORMED PRACTICES TO SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES
IMPACTED BY DISCRIMINATION,
HARASSMENT, AND RETALIATION. WE
HAVE ALSO KEPT OUR EYE TOWARDS
THE 12 PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THAT HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED. THE
LEGISLATION ALIGNS WITH THE
DIRECTION THAT WE ARE GOING, AND
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PACKAGE. WE HAVE APPRECIATED THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LEGISLATOR
AND YOUR STAFF TO ENHANCE THE
WORK THAT WE ARE ALREADY DOING
AND PROVIDE GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR OUR MEASURES
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
CHANCELLOR GARCIA AND I WILL BE
HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU, CHANCELLOR GARCIA,
AND VICE CHANCELLOR SCHWARZKOPF,
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR NEUMANN, AND
THANK YOU TO BOTH OF YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. AND I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THE CHANCELLOR'S
COMMENTS. IT'S OBVIOUS FROM THE
PASSION IN YOUR VOICE. YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO MAKING PROGRESS. MY
QUESTION IS ACTUALLY FOR MISS
SCHWARZKOPF, WHAT AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD, WHAT ARE THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THAT YOU'RE FACING IN
BOTH CHANGING THE CULTURE BUT
ALSO IMPLEMENTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS? THANK YOU. THE
CHALLENGES ARE THAT THERE IS A
DEARTH OF TITLE NINE AND CIVIL
RIGHTS PRACTITIONERS. THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT IS UNIQUE TO
THE CSU. THIS IS A CHALLENGE
THAT IS ACROSS INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. AND SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THE CHANCELLOR AND I
AND OUR LEADERSHIP HAVE SPOKEN
ABOUT IS HOW WE CAN CREATE A
PIPELINE, HOW WE CAN CREATE OUR
OWN PIPELINE, NOT JUST FOR THE
CSU, BUT ALSO FOR OTHER
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
THE OTHER CHALLENGE THAT FACES
THE CSU, IT'S NOT JUST WITH OUR
CIVIL RIGHTS PRACTITIONERS. IT'S
ALSO WITH THE QUALITY OF
INVESTIGATIONS. EVEN WHEN THE
CSU HIRES OUTSIDE EXTERNAL
INVESTIGATORS, THE VAST MAJORITY
OF WHOM ARE ATTORNEYS, WE DON'T
ALWAYS RECEIVE THE WORK PRODUCT.
THE QUALITY THAT WE WOULD EXPECT.
AND SO ONE OF OUR OTHER AREAS OF
FOCUS IS HOW WE CAN STREAMLINE
AND CREATE AN INFRASTRUCTURE
WITHIN THE CSU TO HAVE THOSE
CONSISTENT INVESTIGATIONS AND
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT UP IN THE AUDITOR
AUDITOR'S REPORT AND IN OUR OWN
INTERNAL ASSESSMENT. I
APPRECIATE THAT. SO HOW MANY
ADDITIONAL LAWYERS DO YOU THINK
YOU NEED TO DO THIS WORK?
CORRECT. ACROSS ALL 23
UNIVERSITIES IN THE SYSTEM? I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE'VE GOTTEN
THAT FAR IN OUR PLANNING. WE'RE
STILL IN THE INITIAL STAGES
WHERE WE'RE CONTINUING TO BUILD
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE, HOWEVER,
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE WILL
BE LOOKING AT OVER TIME. I THINK
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
INVESTIGATORS THAT WE HAVE
SYSTEM WIDE, WHAT OUR CURRENT
POOL IS AND THE NUMBER OF OUR
CASES TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S AN
APPROPRIATE WORKLOAD FOR ALL OF
OUR INVESTIGATORS ACROSS THE
CSU. I APPRECIATE THAT. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NEUMANN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, AND
THANK YOU TO THE CHANCELLOR AND
VICE CHANCELLOR FOR THE
PRESENTATION. AS MENTIONED BY
THE VICE CHANCELLOR, THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WILL BE
COLLECTING DATA ON CAMPUS TRENDS
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS.
HOW WILL THE DATA BE ANALYZED
AND USED TO PREVENT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT FROM REOCCURRING ON
BOTH THE CAMPUS LEVELS AND
SYSTEM WIDE LEVELS, AND HOW WILL
THE INFORMATION BE PROVIDED TO
THE PUBLIC? ABSOLUTELY. SO WE'RE
GOING TO DO TWO DIFFERENT TYPES
OF ANALYSIS AS OUR UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES REPORT TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE, WE'RE FIRST
GOING TO LOOK INDIVIDUALLY AT
EACH OF OUR UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT IF
THERE'S A PATTERN OR A TREND
THAT'S OCCURRING ON THAT
UNIVERSITY CAMPUS THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING THAT PATTERN OR TREND
FOR THAT CAMPUS, WE WILL ALSO
LOOK MORE HOLISTICALLY ACROSS
THE ENTIRE CSU SYSTEM TO SEE, IS
THERE A PATTERN OR TREND, SO
THAT THAT WAY WE CAN ADDRESS
THROUGH OUR PREVENTION,
PROGRAMING AND TRAINING AND
AWARENESS EVENTS. AND SO IT WILL
BE BOTH. AND THEN TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT HOW WE CAN ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY, ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION WILL BE AGGREGATED
INTO A SYSTEM WIDE REPORT WHICH
WILL BE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AND
POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE. GREAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG. NEXT WE
HAVE SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK YOU
AND WELCOME AND THANKS FOR THE
VIGOR WHICH YOU ACCEPTED. THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT AND THEN PUT
THINGS INTO ACTION. AND I
APPRECIATE THE DIFFICULTIES IN
TRYING TO ADDRESS A WHOLE SYSTEM
WIDE ISSUE THAT GOES AROUND THE
STATE, SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
THAT YOU'VE YOU'VE PUT IN A LOT
OF THE RECOMMENDATION. HOW DO
INDIVIDUAL FACULTY MEMBERS AT
DIFFERENT CAMPUSES AND STUDENTS,
HOW DO THEY FEEL THE IMPACT OF
THIS AS YOU TALK ABOUT A CULTURE
SHIFT, IT'S ALWAYS HARD TO HOW
DO WE KNOW THE CULTURE HAS
SHIFTED AND HOW DO THE ACTUAL
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND KNOW THAT?
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT? LET ME
START BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE
STILL AT THE BEGINNING STAGES OF
THIS, AND WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
FOR EXAMPLE, EVERY PRESIDENT HAS
IN THEIR GOALS EVERY YEAR, TITLE
NINE AND COMPLYING TO THE AUDIT
REPORTS AND TO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS, AND THAT'S NEW,
THAT IS NEW. AND ALSO IN THE
TRIENNIAL NUMBER TWO, I TRULY
BELIEVE IN ROLE MODELING. HOW
ARE WE DOING THIS? AND IN MY
OPENING ADDRESS THAT I JUST
TAPED THE OTHER DAY, TITLE NINE
CAL, NAPA AND NAPA ARE
PROMINENTLY DISCUSSED IN THAT
OPENING STATEMENT. NUMBER THREE
IS HOW DO WE HOLD THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ACCOUNTABLE
WHERE THE BOARD, BY THE WAY, IS
ASKING US AT EVERY BOARD MEETING
THEY WANT TO REPORT, WHERE ARE
WE? HOW ARE WE DOING AND KEEPING
US ABREAST? AND NUMBER THREE IS
THAT, AS YOU HEARD, THE VICE
CHANCELLOR SPEAK ABOUT, WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE, THE OURSELVES
AUDITING EVERY THREE YEARS. SO I
CAN'T GIVE YOU AN EXACT BECAUSE
WE JUST STARTED THIS. RIGHT. YOU
NEED TO HAVE TIME TO, TO GET THE
INFORMATION HERE, BUT WE'RE
PAYING ATTENTION. WE'RE SPEAKING
TO OUR PRESIDENTS. I KNOW THE
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS IS
SPEAKING TO THE DIRECTORS AND
SEEING HOW THINGS ARE MOVING.
CHANGE IS HARD FOR PEOPLE, BUT
WE KEEP PUSHING. YEAH, OKAY.
AND, DO YOU HAVE EVERYTHING YOU
NEED FOR THE ELECTRONIC SYSTEM
WIDE DATABASE OR DOES THAT COME
WITH ANOTHER DOES THAT NEED
LEGISLATION AND A BUDGET
REQUEST? THANK YOU. SO WE ARE
ACTUALLY IN THE PROCESS RIGHT
NOW. WE HAVE POSTED THE REQUEST
FOR PROPOSALS. THE RFP, THAT IS
RIGHT NOW OUT AND AVAILABLE. WE
ANTICIPATE ABOUT SIX MONTHS FROM
THE TIME THAT IT WAS POSTED IN
LATE JULY, UNTIL A CONTRACT WILL
BE SIGNED WITH THE VENDOR THAT
IS SELECTED. SO WE WOULD
ANTICIPATE THAT WE WILL KNOW
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THAT IN
JANUARY 2025, INCLUDING THE
OVERALL COST OF WHAT THAT SYSTEM
MIGHT BE BASED ON THE FEATURES
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO HAVE IN
THAT SYSTEM. AND WILL YOU BE
COLLECTING ANY SOGI DATA AT THAT
POINT? YES SO SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AND GENDER IDENTITY DATA, WE
WILL WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE COLLECTING DATA ON THE CASES
SO THAT WE CAN ANALYZE ADVERSE
IMPACT, THAT WE CAN DISAGGREGATE
THAT DATA AND LOOK AT HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE FOR OUR PROTECTED
POPULATIONS, AND, CHANCELLOR, I
REALLY APPRECIATE AND AGREE THAT
YOU NEEDED A WHOLE SYSTEM WIDE
APPROACH TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS
AND CUTTING IT INTO CHUNKS, HOW
HOW DO YOU THINK IT GOT SO BAD?
AND WHAT DO WE DO FROM KEEPING
IT GOING BACK? YOU KNOW, I DON'T
KNOW, IT'S HARD FOR ME TO SAY,
I, I THINK FOR SOME REASON IT
WASN'T A PRIORITY, BUT IT'S A
PRIORITY NOW. IT'S A PRIORITY.
MY GOALS TO THE BOARD. IT'S IN
THE PRIORITY OF EVERY PRESIDENT
TO ME. AND SO HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND THE PRIORITY THE
SAME WAY. BUDGETING IS A
PRIORITY, THE SAME WAY THAT
SCHEDULING OF CLASSES IS
PRIORITY. THE SAME WAY THAT
MAKING SURE THAT THEIR CAMPUSES
ARE MOVING EFFECTIVELY AND
EFFICIENTLY. THIS TOO, IS A
PRIORITY AND THAT IS WHY IT'S IN
THEIR GOALS. WILL IT? THE IDEA
IS TO KEEP OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE
AND THE AUDIT DOES INFORM US AND
HELP US WITH AN OUTSIDE SET OF
EYES. THANK YOU. AND, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN. YOU
KNOW ONE THING. I'LL JUST TAKE A
MINUTE. I THINK THIS WOULD BE
IMPROVED IF YOU HAD ANOTHER BOX
WITH YOUR NAME ABOVE THAT. IN
TERMS OF ACCOUNTABILITY, YOU
HAVE AL LIDDICOAT AT THE TOP AND
I THINK IT WOULD BE IMPROVED.
YES, OF COURSE. THERE YOU GO.
AND CHAIRPERSON, I JUST
REMEMBERED MY LAST QUESTION I
WAS GOING TO ASK. YOU HAVE A IF
I MAY. YES, PLEASE, YOU YOU'VE
HAD TROUBLE MAINTAINING
PRESIDENTS IN THE LAST LITTLE
WHILE, AND PERHAPS SOME OF THEM
BEING GONE IS NOT NOT THE WORST
THING IN THE WORLD. LOOKING AT
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE HERE.
BUT IN CHOOSING NEW PRESIDENTS
AND NEW LEADERSHIP, HOW DO YOU
KEEP THAT AT THE FOREFRONT?
WELL, FIRST OF ALL, WE ASK THE
QUESTION IN THE INTERVIEW AND WE
DO A REALLY DEEP BACKGROUND
CHECKS. THAT'S NUMBER ONE. AND
WE ALSO ASK IN THE INTERVIEW AND
THEN WE DO THE DEEP BACKGROUND
CHECK. SO THERE IS A DISCONNECT.
THAT PERSON IS NOT EVER
CONSIDERED. NUMBER TWO IS
LETTING THEM KNOW WHAT ARE THE
GOALS THAT THEY ARE COMING INTO.
WHAT IS IT THAT THAT CAMPUS
NEEDS AND WHAT DO WE NEED THAT
PRESIDENT TO DO TO STAY ON TASK
ON ALL OF THEIR GOALS THAT
INCLUDE TITLE NINE AND CAL
NETWORK? OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. CHAIR. MADAM
CHANCELLOR, I HAVE TO HAVE TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU. I'VE REALLY
LOST CONFIDENCE IN IN THE CSU. I
KNOW YOU'RE INHERITING A LOT OF
THESE THINGS. YOU'RE RELATIVELY
NEW, BUT AS I USED TO BE A PROUD
GRADUATE OF THE CSU, I USED TO
BE A PROUD FORMER MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES, BUT GIVEN
SOME OF THE THINGS, IT'S NOT
JUST ON THIS ISSUE. I MEAN, THE
WAY NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS HAVE
BEEN HANDLED, THE WAY THAT,
ISSUES REGARDING HOMELESSNESS,
STUDENTS AT THE CSU, THE WAY
THAT MANY OF YOUR
REPRESENTATIVES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO, HAVE
MISCHARACTERIZED SOME OF OUR
BILLS IN THE PAST AND HAVEN'T
HAD, HAVEN'T HAD HONEST
CONVERSATIONS HOW CSU GROUPS
HAVE DISTRIBUTED THIS, HAVE HAD
UNPROFESSIONAL BEHAVIOR, HEARING
HEARINGS, PARTICULARLY WITH
ROTH'S BILL ON THAT, THAT WE HAD
A HEARING ON. IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THE WORST HAS HAPPENED THAT
USUALLY HAPPENS TO MANY SYSTEMS
AND INSTITUTIONS, AND THAT IS
PRIORITIZING THE SYSTEM OVER
DOING WHAT'S RIGHT. AND THE
PEOPLE IN WHICH THE SYSTEM
SERVES, THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
STUDIED SYSTEMS KNOW THAT THIS
CAN HAPPEN, BUT IT TAKES BOLD
LEADERSHIP TO UNDO A LOT OF
THAT. AND I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS, NUMBER ONE, I'VE BEEN VERY
IMPRESSED WITH THE WAY THE
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ANSWERED.
AND DEFINITELY KNOW YOUR STUFF,
AND SO I FEEL MORE CONFIDENCE IN
THAT. BUT OVERALL, HOW HOW DO
YOU PLAN ON INSTILLING GREATER
CONFIDENCE IN A SYSTEM IN WHICH
WE TOUT AS CALIFORNIA, AS ONE,
AS A SHINING STAR FOR THE NATION?
LET ME BEGIN BY SAYING YOU HAVE
LOST CONFIDENCE AND WE
UNDERSTAND IT. I UNDERSTAND WHY
WE DID NOT MEET THE EXPECTATIONS
OF TAKING CARE OF FACULTY, STAFF
AND STUDENTS. AND I'M SORRY I'M
TALKING THIS WAY BECAUSE I WANT
TO TALK TO YOU. OKAY, I'LL MOVE
OVER, MOVE OVER, MOVE OVER.
UNDERSTAND THAT I GOING FORWARD,
I AM THE NEW CHANCELLOR. I AM
COMMITTED, I AM A. IF YOU CHECK
MY BACKGROUND, I AM C¢M STUDENT
CENTERED FIRST AND PEOPLE FIRST.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES UP A SYSTEM.
IT IS. HOW DO I HOLD ACCOUNTABLE
THE WAY THE BOARD IS HOLDING ME
ACCOUNTABLE TO MEET YOUR
EXPECTATIONS AND MINE? THAT THE
CSU IS A MODEL SYSTEM FOR THE
NATION. YOU'VE LOST TRUST AND
IT'S GOING TO TAKE TIME FOR YOU
TO GAIN TRUST IN US, BUT HOLD US
ACCOUNTABLE. EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE WITH TITLE NINE AT
THE CAL NAGPRA, WE SAID THE SAME
THING. WE'RE MOVING FORWARD.
HERE'S WHAT WE'VE DONE. WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE TRIBES. WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT STUDENTS,
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS, FACULTY
AND STAFF AND FINALLY HOLDING
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE? I DON'T
BELIEVE IN UNCIVIL
CONVERSATIONS. THAT'S OUT OF THE
QUESTION. IT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THIS COUNTRY HAS TO GET BACK TO
HOW DO WE HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WHERE WE AGREE TO DISAGREE, BUT
WE WALK AWAY FEELING LIKE, OKAY,
WE HURT EACH OTHER. WE
UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER. ALL I CAN
SAY TO YOU IS, YES, WE HAVE
FAILED IN THE PAST. WHAT WE'RE
MOVING FORWARD TO BE BETTER AND
BETTER AS WE MOVE FORWARD. I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. THANK
YOU, YOU KNOW, I CERTAINLY HEAR
YOUR YOUR PASSION ABOUT THIS
ISSUE, AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR IT,
THIS IS A REALLY THESE ARE
REALLY, REALLY DIFFICULT, STICKY
ISSUES. YOU KNOW, I SPENT 20
YEARS IN THE FILM INDUSTRY,
WHICH HAS HAD A PROBLEM WITH
HARASSMENT OVER THE YEARS. AND I
SPENT EIGHT YEARS HERE, WHICH
HAS HAD A PROBLEM WITH
HARASSMENT OVER THE YEARS. AND,
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE A FEW LITTLE
THINGS THAT I'VE LEARNED. FIRST
OF ALL, I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS. I DO KNOW
THAT SOLVING THEM IS NOT GOING
TO COME FROM YOU, OR TEN PEOPLE,
OR 20 PEOPLE, THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS THAT REALLY IS
SYSTEMIC IN OUR SOCIETY THAT IS
NOT GETTING BETTER. AND THAT YOU
HAVE SOME VERY UNIQUE
CHALLENGES. AND TO ME, IT SEEMS
THAT ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES YOU HAVE IS THAT A
LARGE AMOUNT OF YOUR VICTIMS,
SOME OF THEM ARE FACULTY, BUT
MANY OF THEM MOST PROBABLY ARE
STUDENTS. AND THESE ARE
PRIMARILY YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
JUST MAYBE HAVING THEIR FIRST
ADULT EXPERIENCE, AND THEY'RE
NOT NECESSARILY GOING TO KNOW
WHAT HARASSMENT LOOKS LIKE. IN
FACT, MANY ADULTS DON'T KNOW
WHEN A LINE HAS BEEN CROSSED OR
WHAT IT WHAT IT MEANS
NECESSARILY. THEY OFTEN DON'T
RECOGNIZE WHAT'S HAPPENING UNTIL
THERE'S UNTIL IT REALLY BECOMES
EGREGIOUS, WHICH IS HOW THINGS
END UP BUILDING UP IN THE
WORKPLACE, OR THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW TO RESPOND. AND THERE'S A
LOT OF EVIDENCE THAT PEOPLE,
PARTICULARLY WOMEN, EVEN THOSE
OF US WHO HAVE BEEN IN THESE
SITUATIONS WHEN WE'RE FACED IN A
MOMENT OF AN IMPROPER SITUATION,
FREEZE UP. YOU KNOW, THERE WAS A
RECENT STUDY DONE WITH, WITH
INTERVIEWS WHERE WOMEN WHO WERE
PROFESSIONAL WOMEN WHO SAID THAT
THEY KNEW WHAT TO DO WHEN THEY
WERE SORT OF PRESENTED WITH
SOMETHING IN THE IN THE HEAT OF
THE MOMENT FREEZE. SO GIVEN THAT,
I'M NOT GOING TO ASK FOR AN
ANSWER NOW, BUT I DO THINK THAT
YOU HAVE TO WHAT I HAVEN'T SEEN
IN THIS PRESENTATION IS WHAT
YOU'RE DOING TO SPREAD
INFORMATION IN A MEANINGFUL WAY
TO THE STUDENT POPULATION,
BECAUSE WHATEVER RULES YOU HAVE
FOR YOUR FACULTY, WHATEVER
RESPONSE YOU HAVE SET UP, WHICH
I KNOW IS ALSO IT'S NOT EASY TO
SET THAT UP. BUT LET'S ASSUME
YOU SET UP A GREAT TRACKING AND
REPORTING SYSTEM. IT'S NOT GOING
TO WORK IF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO REPORT AND HOW TO
REPORT. YOU HAVE THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS HANDING THEM A PIECE OF
PAPER OR HANGING SOMETHING UP IN
A BATHROOM. IS NOT GOING TO
WORK. I CAN TELL YOU FROM
EXPERIENCE, THEY HAVE GOT TO
INTERNALIZE AND UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT HARASSMENT LOOKS
LIKE AT THE VERY BEGINNING, AND
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE RESPONSES
AND THE APPROPRIATE RESPONSE.
IT'S ALSO NOT BINARY. IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE SOMETHING WHERE IT'S
EITHER FIRABLE OR IT'S NOT.
THERE'S GOT TO BE WAYS, OF
COURSE, CORRECTING EARLY ON SO
THAT PEOPLE HAVE A CHANCE OF
SAVING THEIR OWN CAREERS,
CORRECTING THEIR BEHAVIOR, YOU
KNOW, NOT VICTIMIZING OTHER
PEOPLE BECAUSE SOMETIMES PEOPLE
WHO ARE PERPETUATING THIS
ACTUALLY DON'T. SOME PEOPLE ARE
PREDATORS, SOME PEOPLE KIND OF
FALL IN THE MIDDLE WHERE THEY
DON'T REALLY KNOW THAT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS CROSSING A
LINE. OR IF THEY DO, YOU KNOW,
UNTIL SOMEONE REALLY CALLS THEM
ON IT, THEY MIGHT BE RELUCTANT
TO STOP. SO THERE'S A WHOLE WIDE
RANGE OF BEHAVIOR AND OF
RESPONSES AND OF UNDERSTANDING,
AND SO I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING THINGS FOR YOU IS
GOING TO BE WHAT IT'S BEEN HERE,
QUITE HONESTLY, IS HOW DO YOU
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE IS ON
THE SAME PAGE THAT PEOPLE
RECOGNIZE WHEN THEY'RE BEING
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF, WHEN THEY'RE
IN A POSITION THEY SHOULDN'T BE
IN, YOU KNOW, WHEN MAYBE IT'S
YOU KNOW, THEY MIGHT MAYBE IT'S
NOT COOL TO BE HAVING AN AFFAIR
WITH A PROFESSOR. YOU MIGHT, YOU
KNOW, WHEN YOU MIGHT THINK IT IS
KIND OF A COOL PLACE TO BE. SO,
YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT TO RESPOND, BUT, YOU KNOW,
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO MAKE THIS
SOMETHING THAT REALLY IS A
SYSTEMIC UNDERSTANDING? TOTALLY,
TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU. I WAS A
UNIVERSITY PRESIDENT AT THREE
PLACES, AND NOT ONLY HAVE I SEEN
THAT WITH MY STUDENTS, I SAW
THAT WITH ONE OF MY FAMILY
MEMBERS IN A UNIVERSITY THAT DID
NOT COME FORWARD BECAUSE SHE WAS
AFRAID. SO I GET THIS. AND IF
YOU THINK I'M PASSIONATE, IT'S
BECAUSE IT'S HAPPENED WITH
STUDENTS THAT I SERVED AND
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT AND LET'S BE
FRANK, AS WOMEN, WE HAVE FELT IT
TOO. SO THAT'S WHY I'M SO
PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS. WE ARE
WORKING RIGHT NOW AND WE WILL
GET YOU MORE DETAIL THAT I
GUARANTEE YOU WITH OUR
PRESIDENTS TO MAKE SURE THROUGH
OUR VICE PRESIDENT FOR STUDENT
AFFAIRS THAT IT'S TALKED ABOUT
AT ORIENTATION, THAT IT'S TALKED
TO THROUGH CCSA, THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SEND THE MESSAGE,
WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE? WHERE DO
YOU REPORT? WHAT IS THE PROCESS?
NOT ONLY A PIECE OF PAPER, BUT
THAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT IT IN
THE CLUBS WITH THE FACULTY, SO
THAT WE UNDERSTAND EACH
PRESIDENT IS DOING IT
DIFFERENTLY. THEY'LL REPORT TO
US HOW THEY'RE DOING IT, AND
WE'LL GET SOME INFORMATION BACK
TO YOU. BUT I AGREE WITH YOU
HAVING A SYSTEM IS NOT GOOD
UNLESS PEOPLE KNOW WHAT THE
SYSTEM IS, HOW IT'S GOING TO
HELP THEM, AND HOW WE HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE AND HOW WE
DEMONSTRATE THAT WE'RE HOLDING
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE. RIGHT. WELL,
I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT BECAUSE
THAT THAT ONGOING DISCUSSION,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE NEW STUDENTS
AS THEY COME IN, IS GOING TO BE
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING. AND,
YOU KNOW, IT'S ONE THING TO HAVE
PEOPLE REPORT, BUT ALSO TO TRAIN
YOUNG PEOPLE TO NOT BE WILLING
VICTIMS TO PUT THEMSELVES IN
POSITIONS TO UNDERSTAND, YOU
KNOW, WHEN THEY'RE I MEAN, QUITE
HONESTLY, FOR LACK OF A BETTER
WAY OF SAYING WHEN THEY'RE BEING
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF IS, YOU KNOW,
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT. AND
THAT'S NOT GOING TO COME, AS,
YOU KNOW, THROUGH A RULE ON
PAPER, IT'S GOING TO COME
THROUGH REALLY DISCUSSING THIS
WITH THEM SO THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND, BECAUSE THEY MAY
NEVER HAVE HAD THESE
CONVERSATIONS BEFORE, EVER, IN
THEIR LIVES. THEY MAY NEVER HAVE
BEEN IN A POSITION, AND THEY MAY
NOT KNOW HOW TO REACT OR HOW
THEY SHOULD BE REACTING. WHEN
SOMEONE WHO'S IN A POSITION OF
AUTHORITY IS PREYING ON THEM AND
VICTIMIZING ON THEM AND MAKING
SURE THAT YOU KNOW ALL THE, YOU
KNOW, THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
THOSE POSITIONS OF AUTHORITY
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE IN AN
UNEQUAL POWER BALANCE WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE YOUNG AND THAT
THEY NEED TO, YOU KNOW, TAKE
THEIR, YOU KNOW, BE REALLY
CONSCIOUS OF THEIR OWN ACTIONS
AT EVERY MOMENT AND MAKING AND
CONTINUING THAT WORK AND HAVING
A WAY OF WEAVING IT INTO ALL OF
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE. RIGHT FROM
ORIENTATION GOING FORWARD. I
COMMEND YOU FOR YOU KNOW, HAVING
AN UNDERSTANDING OF THAT. AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
THAT ANY OF THIS IS GOING TO
WORK. I TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU.
NOW, LET ME AND I UNDERSTAND
ALSO HOW CHALLENGING IT IS, AND
LET ME SWITCH GEARS FOR A
MINUTE. SO WE ARE I'M WORKING ON
A BILL THIS YEAR AB 810. THAT'S
ABOUT THE REPORTING OF
HARASSMENT FROM UNIVERSITY TO
UNIVERSITY, BECAUSE AS WE'VE
SEEN AND AS THE REPORT SHOWS, WE
STILL HAVE HAD A SITUATION, YOU
KNOW, EVEN IN RECENT TIMES WHERE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING POSITIVE
LETTERS OF RECOMMENDATION, EVEN
THOUGH THERE HAVE BEEN
INVESTIGATIONS AND SUSTAINED
ALLEGATIONS OF HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION. YOU KNOW, I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU ARE NOW
CORRECTING THAT. I WOULD STILL
LIKE TO HEAR SOME ELABORATION OF
WHAT THOSE LETTERS ARE. YOU
KNOW, IT SEEMS TO ME, AND THIS
IS NOT A UNIVERSITY THING, BUT
JUST WITH EMPLOYMENT IN GENERAL,
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE'VE GOTTEN TO
A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE FEEL THAT
THEY ALWAYS HAVE TO GIVE PEOPLE
POSITIVE LETTERS OF
RECOMMENDATION, EVEN IF THEY'VE
NOT BEEN GREAT EMPLOYEES. YOU
KNOW, I THINK THAT THAT JUST
HURTS OTHER EMPLOYERS. BUT AT
WHAT POINT ARE YOU SAYING WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GIVE A LETTER OR
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE POSITIVE?
YOU KNOW, MY BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THAT THEY ARE REPORTED TO THE
NEXT, YOU KNOW, EMPLOYER. AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. I DON'T THINK IT
SHOULD BE I THINK IT SHOULD BE
WHAT I THINK WHETHER YOU HIRE
THAT PERSON SHOULD BE VOLUNTARY,
BUT EVERY EMPLOYER SHOULD KNOW
IF THERE HAVE BEEN SUSTAINED,
YOU KNOW, ALLEGATIONS OF
HARASSMENT. AND, AND
DISCRIMINATION OR RETALIATION.
BUT HOW HOW ARE YOU IMPLEMENTING
THIS? HOW IS THIS GOING TO WORK?
WHO WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR DOING
THIS? IS IT. YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
SEEN WHERE PEOPLE JUST WANT TO
GET PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR
DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE THEY'RE A
PROBLEM. SO THEY'LL WRITE THAT
LETTER OF RECOMMENDATION, YOU
KNOW, HOW ARE YOU GOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AND THAT OTHER UNIVERSITIES AND
OTHER COLLEGES, HIGH SCHOOLS,
ETC. ARE WARNED? IF THERE'S
SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN A PROBLEM, WE
DO HAVE A PROCESS. THE BOARD DID
PASS SOMETHING IN MARCH 2024,
AND HALEY HAS ALL THE DETAILS.
YES, VICE CHANCELLOR, THANK YOU.
AND, I'M AWARE OF YOUR BILL. I
THINK IT IS GREAT THAT WE SHOULD
BE SHARING THAT INFORMATION. SO
WE'RE NOT IN A PASS. THE
HARASSER SITUATION WITH RESPECT
TO THE CSU'S POLICY, INCLUDING
OUR EMPLOYMENT REFERENCE POLICY,
OUR BOARD OF TRUSTEES DID REVISE
THAT POLICY SO THAT THOSE
LETTERS OF REFERENCE ARE NOT
HAPPENING WHEN THERE IS ANY TYPE
OF A MISCONDUCT FINDING,
INCLUDING SEXUAL HARASSMENT, BUT
OTHER FORMS OF MISCONDUCT AS
WELL. IN ADDITION, WHEN THE CSU
IS CONTACTED REQUESTING A
REFERENCE, WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE WHERE BEFORE A
REFERENCE CAN BE GIVEN, YOU HAVE
TO CHECK WITH HUMAN RESOURCES,
OUR FACULTY AFFAIRS AND THE
TITLE NINE AND HR OFFICE. OUR
CIVIL RIGHTS PRACTITIONERS, TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE NOT GIVING A
REFERENCE WHERE WE SHOULDN'T BE.
IN ADDITION, OUR POLICY IS VERY
CLEAR THAT THE CSU SYSTEM IS ONE
SYSTEM WE WILL BE OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT SO THAT WE ARE NOT
PASSING THE HARASSER BETWEEN OUR
OWN UNIVERSITIES AS WELL, OR TO
OTHER INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. SO DOES THAT MEAN
THAT YOU DON'T WRITE A LETTER AT
ALL, OR THAT THE LETTER JUST
SAYS THEY WORKED HERE? I MEAN,
ARE THERE DIFFERENT SORT OF
GRADATIONS? SO IF SOMEONE IS, I
UNDERSTAND IF THEY'RE
TERMINATED, THAT'S ONE THING.
BUT IF SOMEONE IS STILL STAYING,
YOU KNOW, THEY'VE HAD
INCIDENCES. HOW DO YOU KIND OF
HANDLE THAT? I MEAN, CLEARLY
MAYBE IT WASN'T EGREGIOUS ENOUGH
FOR YOU TO TERMINATE THEM, YOU
KNOW, KIND OF WHAT WHAT WOULD
THAT LETTER SAY AND HOW WOULD
THAT WORK? ABSOLUTELY. SO IT'S A
TWO PART QUESTION. THE FIRST IS
IF THEY ARE TERMINATED, THEY'RE
NOT ELIGIBLE. IF THEY'RE NOT
RETAINED FOR ANY REASON, THEY'RE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR A LETTER OF
REFERENCE. IF THEY ENGAGED IN
MISCONDUCT. BUT IT DIDN'T
WARRANT TERMINATION OR
SEPARATION FROM EMPLOYMENT. WE
ARE STILL VERY CLEAR IN OUR
POLICY. WE CANNOT GIVE A
POSITIVE LETTER OF
RECOMMENDATION IF THE EMPLOYEE
ASKS. SO OUR POLICY DOESN'T HAVE
A TIME LIMIT. SAY WE HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO 15 YEARS AGO THERE
WAS A SUBSTANTIATED FINDING OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND THEY SAY,
I'M GOING ON. I'VE LEARNED FROM
MY MISTAKES. I HAVE HAD A
POSITIVE RECORD FOR THE LAST 15
YEARS. WILL YOU PUT THAT ON
PAPER? THE CSU, OUR POLICY SAYS
WE WOULD, BUT WE HAVE TO OUTLINE
THE FACTS, NATURE AND
CIRCUMSTANCES. WE ARE AN
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER EDUCATION,
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS SHOULD BE
HAPPENING WITH THE EMPLOYEE AND
THEIR FUTURE EMPLOYER, WITH
RESPECT. BUT WE WILL BE HONEST
AND TRANSPARENT AND OPEN. WHEN
YOU SAY FACTS AND CIRCUMSTANCE,
YOU MEAN THERE HAVE BEEN THIS
INCIDENT? IT WAS 15. OKAY, GOOD.
I'M GLAD TO HEAR IT. THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN. SENATOR
LAIRD, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, AND
FIRST LET ME SAY, THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE JOB AS CHANCELLOR,
BECAUSE YOU CAME AT A TIME WHEN
THERE WERE UNBELIEVABLE SERIES
OF CHALLENGES. AND SO YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO DEAL WITH THEM IS
GREAT. I HAVE ONE OBSERVATION
FROM MY COLLEAGUES, AND THAT IS,
IS THAT SENATOR EGGMAN AND I SIT
ON THE RULES COMMITTEE, AND IT
WAS THE MISFORTUNE OF FOUR OF
YOUR TRUSTEES TO BE UP FOR
CONFIRMATION WITHIN DAYS AFTER
YOUR PREDECESSOR RESIGNED. AND
SO WHEN WE HAD THE CONFIRMATION
HEARING, THE ISSUE OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AT THE CSU WAS FRONT
AND CENTER. AND IT HAS BEEN FOR
THE SUBSEQUENT CONFIRMATIONS.
AND SO IT WAS REFRESHING TO HEAR
YOU WERE HEARING FROM YOUR BOARD.
BUT THEY ARE HEARING FROM US AND
WE REALLY LAY IT OUT IN THE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS THAT THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE AS SENATE
DOING CONFIRMATIONS REALLY WANT
ATTENTION PAID TO. A LOT OF THE
THINGS I WAS GOING TO GET TO
THAT HAVE BEEN ASKED, BUT A
COUPLE OF FOLLOW UPS AND ONE IS
SENATOR EGGMAN ASKED ABOUT
BUDGET, AND YOUR RESPONSE WAS
UNCLEAR BECAUSE IT WAS LIKE, OH,
WE'LL KNOW IN JANUARY. DO YOU
KNOW IN JANUARY THAT YOU'LL HAVE
AN EXPENDITURE THAT YOU ALREADY
HAVE BUDGETED? DO YOU KNOW THAT
IN JANUARY THAT WILL TELL YOU,
OH, WE NEED MONEY FOR THAT. WE
DON'T HAVE IT BUDGETED. IT'S
UNCLEAR TO ME WHAT THE STATUS IS
OF WHETHER YOU HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO DO WHAT YOU'RE GOING OUT TO
BID FOR. THANK YOU. SO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLARIFY.
OUR FISCAL TEAM HAS ALLOCATED,
AN AMOUNT FOR US. IT'S AN
ESTIMATE RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE BIDS BACK,
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHO THE
VENDOR IS GOING TO BE. I DON'T
HAVE ANY DETAILS ON HOW MUCH
THAT IS GOING TO COST. HOWEVER,
WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT THE CSU
HAS PRIORITIZED THIS. WE DO HAVE
FUNDING THAT IS ALLOCATED, AND I
HAVE A COMMITMENT FROM THE
CHANCELLOR, FROM OUR BOARD AND
FROM OUR FISCAL TEAM THAT WE
WILL HAVE A SYSTEM. AND IF IT
COSTS MORE THAN WHAT WE'VE
INITIALLY ESTIMATED, THAT WE
WILL FIND THE FUNDS FOR THAT
SYSTEM. AND WE HAVE ALLOCATED
THIS YEAR 15.9 MILLION. BUT FOR
THINGS THAT ARE REQUIRED, LIKE
THIS SYSTEM THAT WE NEED, IT
WILL BE COVERED. OKAY AND
OBVIOUSLY I WORK WITH YOU ON
BUDGET ISSUES. YES YOU DO. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'LL BE
CURIOUS TO HEAR IF, AND THEN MY
OTHER QUESTION, THERE HAVE BEEN
LOTS OF QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW YOU
SORT OF FROM THE TOP DO THIS
AND, AND I JUST ALSO ON RULES WE
DO ALL THE, THE COMPLAINTS AND
ACTIONS UNRELATED THINGS. AND
WHILE IT'S COMPLETELY
CONFIDENTIAL I CAN MAKE ONE
OBSERVATION AND THAT IS IN THE
PLACES WHERE THERE IS SORT OF
BEEN MULTIPLE CASES. IF THERE IS
DISCIPLINE APPLIED, WE HAVE
STARTED TO SEE THE BEHAVIOR
CHANGE IN THOSE PLACES IN A WAY
THAT WE'RE NOT GETTING
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS. AND SO I
THINK THAT FOLLOWING UP ON
EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID YOU WERE
GOING TO DO FROM THE TOP WOULD
MAKE THAT HAPPEN THERE. AND THAT
IS GOOD. MY QUESTION IS, IS THAT
I DID THIS FOR A 2700 EMPLOYEE
COUNTY GOVERNMENT. I WAS THE
PERSON THAT DID DISCIPLINARY
STUFF AND GRIEVANCES. AND THEN I
HEADED IN 19,000 PERSON STATE
AGENCY. AND THE THING I OBSERVED
IS THERE WAS PARTICULARLY
EGREGIOUS SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR
THINGS WHEN YOU WERE WAY AWAY
FROM CENTRAL OFFICES OR CENTRAL
AUTHORITY. I MEAN, IT'S A
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS HAVE
PROBABLY RUN, BUT THE PUBLIC
WORKS ROAD CREWS WERE LIKE JUST
THE CENTER OF THE UNIVERSE FOR
SOME OF THIS STUFF BECAUSE THEY
WERE OUT IN THE MIDDLE OF
NOWHERE. THERE WAS NOBODY
SUPERVISING THEM. AND I FOUND
HAVING 280 STATE PARKS ALL OVER
THE UNIVERSE AND WATER DELIVERED
500 MILES AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
PEOPLE WERE ALL OVER THE PLACE
IN REMOTE LOCATIONS. YOU HAVE
ALL THESE CAMPUSES AND ALL THESE
DIFFERENT PIECES OF THE CAMPUS.
AND WHILE YOU'VE OUTLINED THE
POLICY THAT YOU'RE REALLY GOING
TO DO CLEARLY, HOW DO YOU KNOW
IT'S REACHING ALL THE NOOKS AND
CRANNIES THAT EXIST IN THE SAME
KIND OF REMOTE PLACES AS THE
SAME PLACES WHERE THERE'S NOT
JUST THIS CLOSELY HELD
SUPERVISION? SO I'LL BEGIN AND
THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO OUR
VICE CHANCELLOR HERE. I WILL
SAY, FIRST OF ALL, IT'S THERE
ARE PEOPLE THAT SUPERVISE
WHATEVER UNIT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT, AND YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY GET THERE, THAT
THEY'RE BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR UNITS AND THAT THEY
HAVE TO PRESENT A PLAN ON HOW
THEY'RE DOING IT WITHIN THEIR
UNITS AND MAKE SURE THAT OUR
PEOPLE THAT ARE FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ARE CHECKING
ON ALL THE UNITS, NOT JUST ONE.
WHEN YOU GET TOGETHER AT THE
CAMPUS LEVEL WITH OUR NEW
PERSONNEL, THEY SHOULD BE
CHECKING ON EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENS ON THAT CAMPUS,
INCLUDING THOSE REMOTE OR THOSE
OFF CAMPUS FACILITIES THAT WE
HAVE. IT'S JUST NOT ONE. SO
THAT'S THE FIRST THING THEY HAVE
TO DO. MEANING THAT THE
SUPERVISOR IS ACCOUNTABLE AND
THE SUPERVISOR COULD BE
DISCIPLINED IN A CLEAR WAY IF
THERE'S REGULAR STUFF IN THE
REMOTE PLACE. ABSOLUTELY THE
SUPERVISOR, JUST LIKE I HOLD THE
VICE CHANCELLORS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THEIR UNITS.
AND THE PRESIDENT'S WHOLE VICE
PRESIDENTS AND DEANS ACCOUNTABLE.
THE SAME THING HAPPENS WITH
DIRECTORS. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
I DO IS, AS I DID THIS
YESTERDAY, IS SIT TOGETHER WITH
THE UNIT, THE VICE CHANCELLOR,
AND EVERYBODY THAT REPORTS TO
THAT VICE CHANCELLOR SAYING,
HERE ARE MY EXPECTATIONS AND
HERE ARE MY GOALS. SO THEY'RE
HEARING IT FROM ME AND THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN ON THE
CAMPUSES AS WELL. I WOULD ALSO
SAY THE CSU HAS BEEN VERY
FORTUNATE THAT FOR MANY YEARS WE
HAVE REQUIRED ANNUAL TRAINING
FOR ALL OF OUR EMPLOYEES, AND
THOSE ANNUAL TRAININGS ARE
TRACKED BY CAMPUS, AND THAT
INFORMATION IS INCLUDED IN OUR
PRESIDENT EVALUATIONS. THE
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS ALSO
HELPS TO PROVIDE INPUT ON THOSE
EVALUATIONS EVERY YEAR. THE
OTHER PIECE IS THAT WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE ROBUST
REPORTING. AND SO PART OF THAT
IS GETTING TO OUR EMPLOYEES AND
SHARING WITH THEM THAT WHEN THEY
COME FORWARD, THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO HAVE A ROBUST PROCESS
THAT WORKS IN THE WAY THAT IS
INTENDED TO WORK. AND RIGHT NOW
WE ARE TRANSFORMING THAT SYSTEM.
WE RECENTLY REVISED OUR
NONDISCRIMINATION POLICY TO MAKE
IT MORE USER FRIENDLY FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES, AND WE
ARE CREATING NEW PREVENTION,
EDUCATION AND TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE CSU
FOR ALL LEVELS FOR OUR
EXECUTIVES, SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS. OUR EMPLOYEES AND OUR
STUDENTS. SO IT'LL BE CONSISTENT
MESSAGING THROUGHOUT AND THEN WE
HAVE TO MAKE IT EASY FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO REPORT WHEN THEY GO
TO OUR WEBSITE, WHEN THEY WANT
TO CONNECT WITH OUR TITLE NINE
COORDINATOR OR DR.
ADMINISTRATOR, THAT THEY'RE ABLE
TO FIND THEM EASILY. THEY DON'T
HAVE TO CLICK DOWN TEN LINKS TO
GET TO A FORM. AND SO WE ARE
TRANSFORMING ALL OF THOSE
THINGS. WE ARE LOOKING AT EACH
OF THESE AREAS OF WHERE WE CAN
BE DOING BETTER TO MAKE IT
EASIER AND MORE ACCESSIBLE FOR
OUR STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES.
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU,
SENATOR LEONARD ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
QUIRK-SILVA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
REALLY INSIGHTFUL, NOT ONLY
QUESTIONS, BUT REMARKS, BECAUSE
THIS IS TWO WAY FOR US AS WE SIT
HERE AS LEGISLATORS. IT'S NOT
ONLY HEARING WHAT YOU HAVE TO
SAY. IT'S OF COURSE GETTING THE
INFORMATION FROM THE AUDITOR.
BUT OUR COLLEAGUES WEIGHING IN
ON THEIR LIVED EXPERIENCE. I
HAVE TO SAY THIS IS KIND OF A
TRIGGERING CONVERSATION FOR ME.
THIS IS A DIFFICULT BECAUSE CAL
STATE FULLERTON HAS BEEN THE
CITY. NOT ONLY THAT I GREW UP
IN, THAT I ATTENDED COLLEGE AND
HAVE INTERFACED WITH PRESIDENTS
REALLY FOR ALMOST THE LAST 20
YEARS AS A LOCAL ELECTED AND
THEN ALSO COMING HERE. AND WITH
THOSE LEADERSHIPS, I'VE HAD VERY
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES. AND THE
TRIGGERING PART OF THAT IS WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT ROLE MODELING, WE
ASSUME THAT WHEN SOMEBODY IS
HIRED, WHETHER IT'S AS A
PRESIDENT OF A COLLEGE, AS A
DEAN, FACULTY, EVEN WORKING IN
FOOD SERVICE, THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE MODELING THE BEHAVIOR. AND
YET WE KNOW THAT THAT'S NOT
TRUE. WE ALSO KNOW FOR THE WOMEN
HERE ON THIS PANEL, WE HAVE,
INCLUDING YOU, MANY WOMEN THAT
HAVE GONE THROUGH GENERATIONAL
BEHAVIOR THAT WAS IN MANY TIMES
SEEMED, WELL, THAT'S JUST HOW
THEY ACT. SO WHETHER IT'S A
COUNCIL COLLEAGUE THAT USED TO
CALL ME, YOU KNOW, HONEY OR
DARLING, AND THAT WAS ACCEPTABLE
BECAUSE HE WAS 70 YEARS OLD. AND
AT THAT POINT YOU KIND OF PUT UP
WITH IT, BUT THESE ARE THE
EXPERIENCES THAT WOMEN ENDURE
MYSELF NOT ONLY BEING THE ONLY
FEMALE IN A FULLERTON CITY
COUNCIL, ALL OF THE CITY
MANAGERS AND STAFF BEING MALE,
YOU KNOW, STARTING HAVING THESE
EXPERIENCES. AND WHEN I SAY IT'S
TRIGGERING, HAVING VERY
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES WITH THE
PRESIDENTS AT CAL STATE
FULLERTON, AND I'M GOING TO
LEAVE IT THERE. BUT I'M GOING TO
SAY THAT WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED HERE, PARTICULARLY
WITH YOUNG FEMALES WHO ARE
STUDENTS 18, 19, 20 YEARS OLD,
THIS INTERSECTION OF A
CONVERSATION OF NOT ONLY WHAT
HAPPENS ON A CAMPUS, BUT WHAT
HAPPENS OUTSIDE OF CAMPUSES. AND
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SEXUAL
ASSAULT, WHEN WE TALK ABOUT ALL
OF THESE, THESE ARE ALL
CONVERSATIONS THEY HAVE THE
YOUNGEST, BRIGHTEST FUTURE. AND
THESE CAN BE EXPERIENCES THAT
CAN STAY WITH THEM FOR YEARS.
THESE ARE TRAUMATIC, BUT THEY'RE
ALSO TRAUMATIC FOR WOMEN IN
LEADERSHIP WHEN THEY HAVE THESE
ENCOUNTERS THAT FEEL VERY
PUNITIVE, THAT FEEL, THAT YOU'RE
NOT RESPECTED. SO IT ISN'T
ALWAYS GOING AS FAR AS A
HARASSMENT CASE. IT'S SIMPLY
BEING DISCOUNTED, BEING
MISTREATED AND SADLY, I HAVE TO
SAY, I'VE HAD THAT EXPERIENCE
AND I THINK ALL OF US HAVE HAD
FEMALES THIS. AND SO I REALLY I
SEE THIS SYSTEM DIRECTOR FOR
PREVENTION AND I WOULD REALLY
ENCOURAGE, AS YOU SAID, YOU'RE
MAKING REMARKS TO CLUBS, TO
CAMPUSES. BUT A VERY
INTENTIONAL, VIDEO THAT MODELS
THIS KIND OF STUFF, EXPERIENCES
THAT WE'VE ALL GONE THROUGH THAT
YOU'RE LIKE, OKAY, I KNOW THIS
ISN'T LIKE AN ASSAULT, BUT IT
FEELS REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE. AND
THEN YOU DON'T DO ANYTHING WITH
IT. I HAD A FORMER AND I'M NOT
AGAIN, GOING TO MENTION A
NEIGHBOR, THAT EVERY TIME WE'D
BE IN A PICTURE AS AN ELECTED,
THE HUG WAS JUST TOO MUCH. AND
IT WAS IN A VERY WEIRD PLACE.
AND I JUST THE WAY I'D PATTERNED
THAT WAS JUST MOVING AND NOT
BEING NEXT TO THAT PERSON. BUT
THAT'S REALLY NOT ACCEPTABLE.
AND IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE FOR OUR
YOUNG 20 YEAR OLDS TO GO INTO AN
OFFICE MEETING WITH A PROFESSOR
OR SO FORTH AND FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE, AND THEN WHAT DO
THEY DO? SO A VERY INTENTIONAL,
PREVENTION CAMPAIGN, I GUESS, IS
WHAT I WOULD SAY, BECAUSE IT'S
ONE THING AFTER THESE THINGS
HAVE HAPPENED TO NOW DO WHAT
WE'RE SAYING, WHICH IS YOU'VE
GOT TO REPORT THEM. WE'VE GOT TO
INVESTIGATE THEM. BUT IT'S
ANOTHER THING TO BUILD THIS
CULTURE OF PREVENTION. AND YOUR
NEW FACULTY MEMBERS TO
UNDERSTAND WE CAN'T DO THESE
THINGS THAT MIGHT HAVE HAPPENED
IN THE PAST. THESE ARE NOT
ACCEPTABLE. AND WE'VE CONTINUED
TO HAVE THESE BREAKDOWNS WHERE
SOMEBODY IS USING A RACIAL SLUR
FROM 20 YEARS AGO, AND NOW
PEOPLE CALL THEM ON IT. SO IT
NEEDS TO BE THE SAME WAY UNDER
THIS HARASSMENT AND REALLY
RESPECT OF INDIVIDUALS. THAT'S
VERY INTENTIONAL. AND I'M
PLEASED TO SEE THIS. I HAVE A
LOT OF CONFIDENCE AS YOU KNOW,
IN THIS, CHANCELLOR AND I KNOW
THAT SHE HAS THIS LIVED
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE AT THE AGE WE
ARE, WE HAVE ENDURED A LOT. SOME
OF OUR, MALE COLLEAGUES, I LOVE
YOU TO DEATH, BUT I DON'T THINK
YOU UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT IT
HAS BEEN. AND TO HAVE AND IT
ISN'T. AND WHEN I SAY IT ISN'T A
CSU PROBLEM, THIS IS AN
INSTITUTION PROBLEM WHERE SOME
OF US HAVE BEEN REALLY TREATED
INCREDIBLY DISRESPECTFUL. AND
THAT'S JUST THE THIS IS NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND STUFF. AND SOME
OF US HAVE ENDURED THAT AS WELL.
ABSOLUTELY. BECAUSE A LOT OF
IT'S MIXED IN. SO I'M PLEASED
THAT WE HAVE THIS AUDIT AND
PLEASE, THAT THERE'S COMMITMENT
HERE. BUT REALLY LOOKING AT THE
PREVENTION FROM THE MOMENT NEW
FACULTY, THE MOMENT YOUNG
STUDENTS ENTER THOSE CAMPUSES,
THAT THIS IS THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT WE EXPECT AND THIS IS WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE AND THIS IS WHAT
IT DOES NOT LOOK LIKE. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLYWOMAN QUIRK-SILVA,
YOU DON'T YOU KNOW HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS? I
THINK IT STARTS AGAIN FROM THE
TOP. AND WE ARE GIVING OUR NEW
PRESIDENTS THE TRAINING OF WHAT
IS NOT ACCEPTABLE, NOT ONLY
THROUGH US HERE AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE, BUT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE THEM GO TO THE NEW
PRESIDENTS ACADEMY, WHERE WE
TALK ABOUT WHAT IT FEELS LIKE TO
BE A MODEL PRESIDENT ON A
CAMPUS. WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WHAT YOU CAN'T DO. WHAT IS IT
THAT YOU ARE, PRESIDENT 24 OVER
SEVEN? IT'S NOT ONLY WHILE
YOU'RE ON THE UNIVERSITY SITE,
BUT WHEN YOU GO OFF AND YOU'RE
SHOPPING IN THE SUPERMARKET OR
YOU'RE AT THE BAR OR WHEREVER
YOU ARE, YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT
AND YOU ARE REPRESENTING THAT
UNIVERSITY AND YOU'RE
REPRESENTING THE CSU, AND YOU
ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. FOR WOMEN
IN OUR AGE GROUP, THIS IS
TRIGGERING. IT'S HAPPENED TO ALL
OF US. AND SO IT'S NOT THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THE YOUNG PEOPLE. WE
KNOW THAT WE'VE GONE THROUGH IT.
AND THE OTHER ROLE MODELING IS,
IS SHARING OUR STORIES, BECAUSE
SOMETIMES THEY THINK THAT WE
HAVEN'T GONE THROUGH THIS, BUT
WE HAVE. AND SO KIND OF DOING
THAT ORIENTATION FOR NEW
PRESIDENTS, MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE ORIENTING OUR FACULTY AND
STAFF AND THAT WILL BE TALKED
ABOUT WITH, I GUARANTEE YOU, WE
WILL TALK TO ALL THE PRESIDENTS
AND OUR EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP
TEAM ABOUT THIS. SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. I ALSO WANTED TO
SHARE THAT. I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. I AGREE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT KNOWS NO
GENDER. WE ALSO KNOW THAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT EXPANDS ACROSS THE
DISABILITY SPECTRUM, ACROSS THE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC SPECTRUM. IT
PARTICULARLY IMPACTS OUR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND
EMPLOYEES ARE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES. THOSE
WHO DON'T FEEL THAT THEY HAVE A
VOICE, WHO CAN COME FORWARD, AND
EVEN WHERE WE HAVE A STUDENT OR
AN EMPLOYEE WHO IS IMPACTED BY
THESE CASES OFF CAMPUS, WE HAVE
SOLUTIONS ON CAMPUS TO SUPPORT
THEM. WE HAVE SUPPORTIVE
MEASURES AVAILABLE. THIS IS PART
OF OUR MESSAGING AND OUR
TRAINING THAT EVEN WHERE IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN WITHIN THE CSU
SYSTEM, WE CAN STILL SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES WHILE
THEY ARE THERE AND LIVING,
LEARNING AND WORKING. SO I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE THAT AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA SENATOR
CHUBBUCK. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
I THINK I ANSWERED ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS MYSELF WITH JUST
READING THE DIFFERENT PLATFORMS,
BUT I DO, I DO HAVE A I HAVE A
QUESTION WITH REGARDS TO THE
INVESTIGATIVE PORTION OF THE OF
THE COMPLAINTS. WOULD YOU MIND
CLARIFYING HOW YOU FOLKS WHO
DOES THE INVESTIGATIONS AND I
UNDERSTAND I REMEMBER YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT THERE'S
DIFFICULTY AND INCONSISTENCY
WITH REGARDS TO THE
INVESTIGATIONS AND THAT YOU'RE
SAYING YOU'RE TRYING TO SEE HOW
YOU CAN, FACILITATE THE IN-HOUSE
OR, INVESTIGATIONS OF, OF, OF
THE, OF THE COMPLAINTS. WOULD
YOU MIND CLARIFYING A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON THAT ASPECT AND, SOME
QUESTIONS I HAD WILL FOLLOW ONCE
WE HEAR FROM HER. FROM YOU.
ABSOLUTELY. SO OUR EACH OF OUR
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES, THEY HAVE
INVESTIGATORS ON STAFF. SO WE
HAVE STAFF INVESTIGATORS WHO ARE
SPECIALLY TRAINED TO INVESTIGATE
COMPLAINTS AS THEY COME IN. WE
ALSO BECAUSE OF WORKLOAD HIRE
EXTERNAL INVESTIGATORS.
SOMETIMES DEPENDING ON THE
COMPLAINT THAT COMES IN, IF IT
REQUIRES A SPECIFIC TYPE OF
EXPERTISE THAT MAYBE OUR
INVESTIGATOR DOESN'T HAVE, THEN
WE WILL ALSO HIRE EXTERNALLY.
AND SO WE HAVE A LIST OF
INVESTIGATORS THAT IS MAINTAINED
BY OUR OFFICE OF GENERAL COUNSEL
OF APPROVED INVESTIGATORS FOR
THE CSU AND ALL OF OUR
INVESTIGATORS, WHETHER THEY ARE
INTERNAL OR EXTERNAL, THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH
SPECIALIZED TRAINING ON THE
CSU'S NONDISCRIMINATION POLICY
AND OUR EXPECTATIONS. THANK YOU.
I THINK THE ONLY CONCERN I, I, I
THINK I HAVE IS THE, THE NOTION
OF HAVING INTERNAL INVESTIGATORS
JUST BECAUSE OF THE POTENTIAL
CONFLICT OF INTEREST THAT MIGHT
OCCUR, OF HAVING THE
INVESTIGATORS WITHIN THE SAME
SYSTEM THAT THEY ARE CURRENTLY
INVESTIGATING. AND THE ONLY
CONCERN I THE ONLY REASON I
SHARE THAT WITH YOU IS THE
CONCERN OR THE OBSERVATION THAT
I HAVE EVEN HERE WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE IN THAT, IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AND, THROUGH THE
CHAIR, I BELIEVE SENATOR LAIRD
COULD CLARIFY FOR ME SINCE HE
SITS ON RULES, THE LEGISLATURE
ACTUALLY HAS INVESTIGATORS
OUTSIDE OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT
COME IN AND INVESTIGATE SOME OF
THOSE COMPLAINTS, IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S INTEGRITY IN
THE PROCESS AND NO CONFLICT OF
INTEREST, OR INTIMIDATION THAT
MIGHT OCCUR, WHEN THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS OR THOSE
COMPLAINTS ARE BEING, FILED AND
INVESTIGATED. SO THAT'S THE ONLY
ONLY RED FLAG THAT I ACTUALLY
BROUGHT WAS CAME TO MY MIND, AS
YOU WERE MENTIONING, THE
INVESTIGATIONS AND CONSISTENCIES
AND SO FORTH, THAT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING YOU MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER WITHIN THAT PROCESS AS
PERHAPS, MAYBE IT'D BE BEST
SUITED IF AN OUTSIDE ENTITY WAS
HIRED OR FULLY HIRED TO DO THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS. SO AS IN THE
FUTURE, THERE ISN'T THAT
POTENTIAL CONFLICT OF INTEREST
OR INTIMIDATION WITHIN THE SAME
SYSTEM. AND IT BECOMES VERY
OBJECTIVE. AND I, YOU KNOW,
WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE, I
THOUGHT IT WAS ONE OF THE VERY,
VERY WISE DECISIONS TO ENSURE
THAT, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
INTEGRITY AND, CONSISTENCY. AND
HONESTY WITHIN THAT SYSTEM. AND
I RESPECT THAT. THE, THE MANNER
IN WHICH THE LEGISLATURE HAS
PROCEEDED WITH THIS, WITH THESE
TYPE OF, OF INVESTIGATIONS. AND
I JUST THOUGHT I'D JUST PLANT
THAT SEED FOR CONSIDERATION IN
THE FUTURE AS YOU FOLKS MOVE
FORWARD IN IMPLEMENTING YOUR,
YOUR PROCESSES WITHIN THE SCOPE.
THANK YOU. AND I WILL SHARE THAT
PART OF THE INTERNAL ASSESSMENT
THAT THE CSU DID WITH THE COZEN
O'CONNOR LAW FIRM. THAT WAS ALSO
ONE OF THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
ARE DISCUSSING WITH LEADERSHIP
FOR HOW TO MOVE FORWARD, MORE
SYSTEMATICALLY FOR THE CSU
SYSTEM. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THANK YOU FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION. AND THANK
YOU, DOCTOR GARCIA, FOR,
COMMITTING YOURSELF TO, YOU KNOW,
SEND, YOU KNOW, SEND A MESSAGE
FROM THE VERY TOP. AND, YOU
KNOW, I, YOU KNOW, HAVE NO DOUBT
THAT YOU ARE GOING TO DO WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING TODAY, THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO, FIGHT TO CHANGE THAT,
THAT CULTURE SYSTEM WIDE. YOU
KNOW, I, I SPEAK, OBVIOUSLY AS
A, YOU KNOW, MALE LEGISLATOR AND
NOT ONLY YOU KNOW, HAVING SEEN A
LOT OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
TRYING TO CHANGE THE CULTURE
RIGHT HERE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE, WHERE WE WENT
THROUGH THE, THE METOO MOVEMENT,
WE WENT THROUGH, YOU KNOW, THE
WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT, EFFORT
THAT THAT IS ONGOING. I'VE, YOU
KNOW, PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED,
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF THOSE,
DIFFICULT DISCUSSIONS. AND I'VE
LEARNED A LOT. I'VE LEARNED A
LOT FROM THOSE ALL OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. AND I THINK, YOU
KNOW, THAT HAVING GONE THROUGH
THAT EXPERIENCE, YOU KNOW, AS A
MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATURE IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO CHANGE THE
HISTORY AND THE CULTURE OF THIS
INSTITUTION, YOU KNOW, I CAN
ONLY IMAGINE HOW MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT IT WOULD BE, YOU KNOW,
FOR YOUR 23 CAMPUSES AND, YOU
KNOW, ALL OF THE EMPLOYEES AND
ALL OF THE STUDENTS, BUT, YOU
KNOW, I, I, I DO BELIEVE THAT,
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
GOING TO BE LIKE AN ONGOING
EFFORT. IT'S NOT GOING TO, YOU
KNOW, END WITH YOUR FIGHT TO, TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE. BUT I'M
OPTIMISTIC THAT YOU ARE GOING TO
HELP, YOU KNOW, PUSH THE BALL
FORWARD, AND I JUST WANT TO SAY,
YOU KNOW, NOT ONLY AM I FULLY
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR EFFORTS TO
CRACK DOWN ON SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TO, TO PROTECT ALL STUDENTS IN
THE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I ALSO SPEAK, AS
A FATHER OF A DAUGHTER WHO'S IN
HIGH SCHOOL WHO MAY BE ATTENDING
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY,
YOU KNOW, CAMPUS IN THE NEAR
FUTURE. AND SO, NOT ONLY AS A
LEGISLATOR, BUT AS A FATHER OF A
DAUGHTER, I, I TRULY HOPE THAT
THAT YOU MOVE THE BALL FORWARD
TO CHANGE THE CULTURE. AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THOSE COMMENTS. I WILL SAY THAT
WHEN STUDENTS COME ON OUR
CAMPUS, FAMILIES ARE ENTRUSTING
THEM TO US, AND THAT IS A HUGE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE HAVE TO
TAKE VERY, VERY SERIOUSLY. AND
AS MY GODDAUGHTER, NIECE BEGINS
COLLEGE THIS YEAR, I'M ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT SHE UNDERSTANDS
AND WORRIED ABOUT HER. THE WAY
YOU ARE TOO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
AND THANK YOU BOTH FOR,
ANSWERING THESE QUESTIONS AND
BEING AVAILABLE FOR TO HEAR THE
CONCERNS AND ISSUES THAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE RAISED. I DO
HAVE ONE QUICK LITTLE QUESTION
THAT I'M NOT CLEAR ABOUT. STILL,
ONE OF THE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS, REGARDED,
ACCUMULATING DATA AND THEN
LOOKING AT TRENDS. AND I WASN'T
CERTAIN FROM YOUR ANSWER WHETHER
THAT IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING NOW
AND HAS ANY OF TRENDS OR
PATTERNS EMERGED FROM THAT DATA
COLLECTION. THANK YOU. SO OUR
DATA COLLECTION IS CURRENTLY
UNDERWAY FROM ALL 23 CAMPUSES
AND THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE,
BECAUSE THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
IS ALSO TREATED AS A CAMPUS,
THAT WILL BE FOR OUR DATA FROM
THE 2023 TO 2024 YEAR. SO JULY
1ST, 2023 TO JUNE 30TH, 2024.
THAT INFORMATION IS REQUIRED TO
BE REPORTED TO THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE BY OCTOBER 1ST. THAT
INFORMATION WILL THEN BE
REVIEWED AND TRANSLATED FOR
PATTERNS AND TRENDS, AND ALSO
REPORTED TO THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY BY DECEMBER 1ST. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING THAT
INFORMATION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU BOTH VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT PANEL ARE
STAKEHOLDERS OF THE CSU SYSTEM.
AND, WE HAVE MISS L ROUHANI,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME, GOOD MORNING.
CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS TARA AL-RIHANI. I AM THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF SYSTEMWIDE
AFFAIRS WITH THE CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION, AND I'M
CURRENTLY PURSUING MY EDUCATION
AT SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY,
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS, OUR
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN
THE VARIOUS REPORTS CONDUCTED ON
THE STATE OF TITLE NINE AND
DISCRIMINATION IN THE CSU
SYSTEM. THIS INCLUDES THE CSU'S
OWN COZEN O'CONNOR REPORT, THE
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT, AND THE
CALL TO ACTION REPORT PUBLISHED
BY THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. AS STUDENTS, WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE ATTENTION AND
THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE TO
IDENTIFY AND ACKNOWLEDGE HOW THE
SYSTEMS THAT HAD BEEN IN PLACE
WERE FAILING US, AND WE HAVE
BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE MADE
AT THE LEGISLATIVE LEVEL. WE'VE
BEEN PROUD TO WORK WITH THE
ASSEMBLY, HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND MANY OTHER OFFICES
ON LEGISLATION THAT COMES
DIRECTLY FROM MANY OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THE
STATE AUDITOR. THERE ARE EIGHT
BILLS THAT WE HAVE A SUPPORT
POSITION ON AB 810 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AB 1905 BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARTIS AB 2047 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG AB. 2326 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ AB 2407
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HART AB 2492
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN AB 2987
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ORTEGA AND
SB 1166 BY SENATOR DODD. WE HOPE
THAT THIS LEGISLATION, THAT THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION COMES TO AN
END AND WE CAN SEE THAT EACH OF
THESE BILLS ARE SIGNED INTO LAW
AND THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE POLICIES CAN HAPPEN
SWIFTLY. WHEN MY PREDECESSOR
CAME TO TESTIFY BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE A YEAR AGO, SHE SHARED
MANY OF THE TITLE NINE CONCERNS
THAT WE AS CSU STUDENTS HAD
INCLUDED. THEY WERE THAT CAMPUS
GRIEVANCE PROCEDURES FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR SAR, ARE OFTEN SEEN
AS UNFAIR AND INEQUITABLE BY OUR
STUDENTS, WITH OUTCOMES VARYING
SIGNIFICANTLY BY CASE. SHE ALSO
MENTIONED COMMON ISSUES,
INCLUDING DISMISSAL OF CASES DUE
TO THE PERPETRATOR'S STATUS, LOW
PRIORITY OR INADEQUATE
INVESTIGATION LEADING TO A LACK
OF DISCIPLINE AND ONGOING
CONTACT BETWEEN SURVIVORS AND
PERPETRATORS, WHICH IS A VERY
HIGH SAFETY CONCERN FOR OUR
STUDENTS, AND THAT OVERALL, ALL
OF THESE PROBLEMS ERODED THE
TRUST IN THE TITLE NINE
GRIEVANCE PROCESS, CAUSING MANY
STUDENT SURVIVORS TO AVOID
FILING FORMAL COMPLAINTS.
HOWEVER, WE ARE HAPPY TO SEE
THAT SINCE SHE HAS SHARED THESE
CONCERNS, THERE HAS BEEN
PROGRESS MADE BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO ADDRESS
MANY OF THEM. WE ARE GLAD THAT
11 RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN
FULLY IMPLEMENTED THUS FAR TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THE INEQUITIES
WITHIN THE TITLE NINE PROCESS.
AS CSU STUDENTS, WE ARE
ESPECIALLY GRATEFUL FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS EIGHT AND TEN,
WHICH ENSURE THE FAIR TREATMENT
OF SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS MAKE
CERTAIN THAT UNIVERSITIES HAVE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES AND THE BEST
PRACTICES FOR HANDLING FORMAL
INVESTIGATIONS. THIS INCLUDES
HAVING DEDICATED EXTERNAL
INVESTIGATORS TO ENSURE
IMPARTIALITY AND CLEAR GUIDANCE
ON HOW TO INITIATE, CONDUCT AND
DOCUMENT DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS.
THESE MEASURES HELP GUARANTEE
FAIR AND EFFECTIVE RESPONSES TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT, SUPPORTING
SURVIVORS THROUGH A TRANSPARENT
AND JUST PROCESS, ALL OF WHICH
IS THE OF THE UTMOST IMPORTANT
IMPORTANCE TO US AS CSU
STUDENTS. AS MANY SURVIVORS ARE
STUDENTS THEMSELVES. ANOTHER
MAJOR CONCERN WE HAVE HAD SINCE
THE ORIGINAL AUDIT WAS, WAS
RELEASED WAS A PROCESS FOR CSU
CAMPUSES TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
OTHER FORMS OF MISCONDUCT THAT
MAY NOT FALL WITHIN THE
PARAMETERS OF TITLE NINE,
ALTHOUGH THERE HAS NOT BEEN A
PROCESS IMPLEMENTED TO ADDRESS
THIS, WE ARE GLAD THAT IT IS
INCLUDED IN THE CSU CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE TITLE NINE UPDATE TO BE
COMPLETED BY JANUARY 2025. AS
STUDENTS, WE BELIEVE THESE OTHER
FORMS OF MISCONDUCT CAN STILL
CREATE A HOSTILE AND UNSAFE
ENVIRONMENT FOR MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS. SO WE ARE ONCE AGAIN
HAPPY TO SEE THIS WILL BE
EVENTUALLY, FULLY IMPLEMENTED. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO THANK THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
FOR THE PROGRESS THAT THEY HAVE
MADE FOR ENSURING THAT THERE IS
STUDENT REPRESENTATION ON EVERY
CAMPUS. TITLE NINE
IMPLEMENTATION TEAM. WE FIRMLY
BELIEVE STUDENTS SHOULD ALWAYS
BE CONSIDERED AS EQUAL
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THIS
ENTIRE PROCESS, AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING HOW ALL OF
THESE IMPLEMENTATIONS AFFECT THE
DAILY LIVES OF OUR STUDENTS.
ONCE WE BEGIN OUR UPCOMING
ACADEMIC YEAR, ESPECIALLY OUR
STUDENT SURVIVORS, WE HOPE THAT
THESE NEW AND IMPROVED PROCESSES
ENSURE THE FAIR TREATMENT,
SUPPORT, AND SAFETY OF SURVIVORS
WHILE ALSO ENSURING
INSTITUTIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY. IN
CONCLUSION, I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THIS JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE, THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE, AND THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY AND FOR CONTINUING TO
ELEVATE THIS ISSUE. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT OUR UNIVERSITIES
ARE SAFE AND SUPPORTIVE FOR US
ALL, AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THIS WORK WITH YOU
ALL AND THE CSU TO ENSURE THAT
IT IS. IT IS IN THE YEARS TO
COME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MISS
AL-RIHANI. APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT WE HAVE TERRY
WILSON, VICE PRESIDENT OF
FINANCE FOR CSU. YOU Â YOU.
GOOD MORNING. CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
TERRY WILSON, AND I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR FINANCE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
EMPLOYEES UNION. THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY ON THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. CSU REPRESENTS
35,000 NON-FACULTY STAFF AND
STUDENTS ACROSS SEVEN BARGAINING
UNITS. OUR REPRESENTATION OF THE
DIVERSE SET OF CSU EMPLOYEES
PROVIDES OUR ORGANIZATION A
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE ON THE TITLE
NINE SYSTEM. AT THE OUTSET, I
WOULD LIKE TO APPLAUD THIS
COMMITTEE. THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE, AND THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR WORK ON RESPONDING TO AND
ADDRESSING THE FAILURES OF THE
TITLE NINE SYSTEM AT THE CSU. AS
YOU KNOW, THE AUDIT REPORT ON
CSU TITLE NINE PROCEDURES
CONFIRMED PROBLEMS THAT OUR
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN OBSERVING AND
EXPERIENCING FOR YEARS,
INCLUDING OUTRAGEOUS CASE
DELAYS, LACK OF DISCIPLINE FOR
THOSE WHO VIOLATE TITLE NINE
POLICIES, AND REFUSAL TO
INVESTIGATE ALLEGATIONS WITHOUT
PROVIDING ANY RATIONALE. THE
AUDIT ALSO NOTED HOW THE LACK OF
STANDARDIZED DATA COLLECTION AND
ANALYSIS ACROSS CAMPUSES
PREVENTS THE CSU FROM
IDENTIFYING AND ADDRESSING
PROBLEMATIC TRENDS. THE
RECOMMENDATIONS PRESENTED IN THE
AUDIT, SUCH AS PROVIDING CLEAR
GUIDELINES TO ENSURE CONSISTENT
INTERPRETATION OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND ESTABLISHING
CONSISTENT METHODS FOR
ADDRESSING SEXUAL HARASSMENT,
ARE STEPS WE MUST TAKE IF WE
HOPE TO FOSTER A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT ON OUR CAMPUSES.
YOUR HEARING LAST YEAR IN THE
WORK ON A CALL TO ACTION
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE WILL ENSURE
THAT THESE ISSUES ARE CORRECTED
IN A SUSTAINABLE FASHION. WHILE
THE CSU HAS MOVED TO CORRECT
SOME OF THESE IDENTIFIED IN THE
AUDIT, I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT THE
MEASURES AND THE CALL TO ACTION
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE ARE CRITICAL
TO FIXING THESE PROBLEMS IN THE
LONG TERM. IN ADDITION TO
LEGISLATIVE ACTION, IT WILL BE
CRITICAL THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT ON
THE HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS.
SO WE DO NOT HAVE THESE ISSUES.
AGAIN, THAT OVERSIGHT SHOULD
COME IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THOSE
REPRESENTING EMPLOYEES AND
STUDENTS IN HIGHER EDUCATION
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ARE CRITICAL IN
ACHIEVING AN INCLUSIVE
ENVIRONMENT TO OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS OVER THE
COMING WEEKS, WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PASS TO PASS THE
BILLS AND THE CALL TO ACTION
PACKAGE. THIS PACKAGE WILL
PROVIDE FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE AND
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO RECEIVE
THE INFORMATION IT NEEDS FOR
FURTHER OVERSIGHT. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
ADDRESS THESE SYSTEMIC ISSUES,
TO BUILD A BETTER, SAFER CSU FOR
STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES ALIKE.
THANK YOU, AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. WILSON. NEXT WE
HAVE DOCTOR ANN LUNA GARDNER,
THE CAPITAL CHAPTER PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIRS AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO RETURN
THIS YEAR TO SHARE OUR FEEDBACK
ON THE PROGRESS MADE IN
IMPLEMENTING THESE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS. WE ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE THAT AFFECTS SO MANY LIVES
DAILY. MY NAME IS ANN LUNA
GARDNER. I'M AN ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR AT SACRAMENTO STATE
AND ONE OF THE TRI CHAIRS OF THE
CFA WOMEN'S CAUCUS. AND I'M A
SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL ASSAULT. CFA
REPRESENTS 29,000 PROFESSORS,
LECTURERS, COUNSELORS, COACHES,
AND LIBRARIANS WHO HAVE BEEN ON
THE FRONT LINES OF TITLE NINE
PROCESS FOR MANY YEARS. WHEN WE
SURVEYED OUR 23 CAMPUSES ON THIS
YEAR'S CHANGES, THEY REPORTED
THAT THE UPDATED FORMS AND
CHECKLISTS WERE A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. WE ALSO HEARD
THAT THE OUTSIDE GROUP THAT WAS
HIRED TO HANDLE ONE PARTICULAR
INVESTIGATION FOR OUR MEMBER WAS
PROFESSIONAL AND EMPATHETIC.
THAT IS A STARK IMPROVEMENT.
HOWEVER, WE ALSO RECEIVED
FEEDBACK THAT THIS YEAR, PEOPLE
ARE STILL WITHDRAWING THEIR
GRIEVANCES BECAUSE THE PROCESS
IS DYSFUNCTIONAL AND TAKES WAY
TOO LONG IN A RECENT CASE, A
MEMBER HAD TO WAIT 27 MONTHS FOR
RESULT THAT PREVENTED THEM FROM
GETTING ANOTHER JOB WHEN THEIR
CONTRACT WAS UP JUST TO HAVE THE
CASE THROWN OUT. SO
UNFORTUNATELY, WE ALSO SEE
REVOLVING DOOR OF INADEQUATE
STAFFING AND A NEED TO FOLLOW UP
AT EACH STAGE. WE ALSO FOUND OUT
THAT ALTHOUGH NEW PROCESSES HAVE
BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN MANY OF OUR
FACULTY, EVEN THOSE ON OFFICIAL
COMMITTEES ON THE SUBJECT DO NOT
FEEL ADEQUATELY ENGAGED. THERE'S
A SIGNIFICANT GAP IN
COMMUNICATION LEAVING CAMPUS
COMMUNITIES UNINFORMED AND
SKEPTICAL. IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT
THE CAMPUS COMMUNITY BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FEEDBACK ON HOW TO REACH
AND IMPACT FACULTY, STAFF, AND
STUDENTS. WE SEEK TO BE
PRODUCTIVE PARTNERS WHILE WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CSU'S EFFORTS TO
CREATE A STRUCTURE THAT
ADDRESSES THESE, TITLE NINE
ISSUES, WE MUST CRITICALLY ASK
WHETHER THESE OFFICES ARE TRULY
FUNCTIONAL AND EFFECTIVE. WE
HAVE LEARNED THAT ADDING MORE
ADMINISTRATORS AT THE TOP DOES
NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM. THE CSU
NEEDS TO MOVE FROM BEING SIMPLY
COMPLIANCE DRIVEN TO A REAL
COMMITMENT TO INNOVATIVE TITLE
NINE POLICY AND PRACTICE. WE
NEED TO WORK TO MINIMIZE AND
ELIMINATE THE PROBLEM, RATHER
THAN MERELY ENSURING THAT
INVESTIGATIONS ARE PROCESSED AND
TRACKED. WE WANT TO APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATURE FOR THE CALL TO
ACTION LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE.
SEVERAL OF THESE BILLS SUPPORT
SURVIVORS AND PROMOTE THE
NECESSARY INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT.
HOWEVER, WE MUST ENSURE THAT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FROM AN
ANTI-RACIST AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
LENS ARE PROVIDED FOR TITLE NINE
OFFICES AND DO NOT PERPETUATE
THESE FLAWED SYSTEMS THAT ARE
ALREADY IN PLACE. WHILE THE CALL
FOR MORE STREAMLINED DATA IS
ALSO A POSITIVE STEP, WE'RE
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THIS
DATA IS BEING TRACKED AND
COMMUNICATED. THE CSU'S TRACK
RECORD ON IMPLEMENTATION IS POOR
AND WITHOUT CLEAR EVIDENCE AND
DOCUMENTATION, REMAIN DOUBTFUL
OF THEIR EFFECTIVENESS. ANY DATA
COLLECTION NEEDS TO TRACK WHO IS
IMPACTED. THE FOCUS MUST BE ON
CAPTURING PATTERNS OF
DISCRIMINATION WITH AN
INTERSECTIONAL APPROACH THAT
RECOGNIZES RACIAL, GENDER,
SEXUAL ORIENTATION, AND
DISABILITY BIASES. WE MUST
REMEMBER TO GROUND OURSELVES IN
THE CORE PURPOSE OF THESE
DISCUSSIONS. PREVENTING SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND HARASSMENT. THE
CURRENT RELIANCE ON PUNITIVE
MEASURES HAS NOT PROVEN
EFFECTIVE IN PREVENTING HARM.
INSTEAD, WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
PREVENTION AND CREATING NEW
NORMS AND SYSTEMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. THE CSU'S
APPROACH MUST EVOLVE BEYOND MERE
COMPLIANCE WITH LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS AND ADDRESS A TRUE
CULTURAL CHANGE NEEDED TO CREATE
A SAFER ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL. IN
CLOSING, WE APPRECIATE THE CSU'S
FOLLOW UP ACTIONS AND THEIR
PLANS FOR ONGOING ADJUSTMENTS.
HOWEVER, THE LEGISLATURE MUST
CONTINUE TO HOLD THE CSU
ACCOUNTABLE, NOT JUST FOR POLICY
AND LEGAL COMPLIANCE, BUT FOR
REAL CULTURAL CHANGE THAT
ADDRESSES THESE SYSTEMIC ISSUES
THROUGH AN ANTI-RACISM AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE LENS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP, AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO THE CSU
SYSTEM. THE THOUGHTFUL REFORMS
THAT WE'RE EMBARKING ON CAN BE A
MODEL FOR OUR STATE AND COUNTRY.
THANK YOU, AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, DOCTOR LUNA, I APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY. ARE THERE
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PANEL, ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG,
THANK YOU SO MUCH, CHAIR HART.
AND THANK YOU TO EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF YOU FOR PROVIDING YOUR
TESTIMONY ON BEHALF OF YOUR
ORGANIZATIONS TODAY. AND AS WE
HEARD FROM SOME OF THE SPEAKERS
DURING OUR LAST HEARING, THERE
WAS A TRUST GAP THAT WAS CREATED
BETWEEN STUDENTS, FACULTY, STAFF
ON CAMPUSES. AS WE HEARD
EARLIER, THE SYSTEM WIDE LEVEL
CHANGES. SO A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS. HOW HAVE THE CHANGES
ON THE SYSTEM WIDE LEVEL
AFFECTED THE TRUST GAP? AND THEN
SECONDLY, AS MENTIONED BY OUR
SPEAKERS HERE, IN ADDITION TO
THE 12 BILL PACKAGE, THE CALL TO
ACTION BILL PACKAGE, WHAT MORE
CAN THE LEGISLATURE DO, TO HELP
PREVENT AND ADDRESS SEXUAL
HARASSMENT, CAMPUSES AT THE CSU
SYSTEM. YEAH. SO, FOR THE FIRST
POINT, FOR THE TRUST GAP, THESE
IMPLEMENTATIONS, WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THEM FULLY ENACTED YET BECAUSE
OUR ACADEMIC SESSION HASN'T
BEGUN YET. SO IT'S A LITTLE TOO
HARD TO TELL JUST, JUST YET,
HOWEVER, I KNOW WITH MY WORK,
WITH THE SYSTEM WIDE AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE, I AM FULLY READY TO
EMPLOY MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
REACH OUT TO THEIR TITLE NINE
OFFICES, WORK WITH THEM CLOSELY,
AND GET ON THE GROUND FEEDBACK
SO THAT I CAN THEN REPORT THAT,
TO BOTH THE CSU CIVIL RIGHTS
IMPLEMENTATION OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE THAT I SIT ON, AND
ALSO, THEN AGAIN, TO ANYONE IN
THE C  WHO'S WILLING TO TAKE
THAT AND THEN ALSO HOPEFULLY TO
THIS COMMITTEE, STUDENTS, I
THINK, NEED TO HEAR A DIRECT
APOLOGY, FOR HOW THEY WERE
TREATED FROM THE INSTITUTION.
THEY WANT TO HEAR. IT'S
DIFFERENT COMING FROM STUDENT
LEADERS WHO ARE SITTING HERE,
YOU KNOW, AS OPPOSED TO THOSE
WHO HAVE MADE THE LEGISLATION
AND THE CHANGES. SO, YEAH, AS
FAR AS SEEING THAT TRUST GAP
CHANGE, WE DO HAVE TO WAIT FOR
THE SCHOOL YEAR FOR THE STUDENT
SIDE AND THE STUDENT
PERSPECTIVE. YEAH THANK YOU,
WITH REGARD TO THE TRUST GAP, I
THINK THERE HAS BEEN A PROBLEM,
AGAIN, WITH COMMUNICATION AND
THAT A LOT OF FOLKS ARE NOT
FEELING LIKE THEY'RE BEING
INFORMED IN A TIMELY MANNER
ABOUT THE THINGS AND THE CHANGES
THAT ARE COMING, JUST TO GIVE AN
EXAMPLE, AT OUR CAMPUS,
SOMETHING CAME DOWN FROM OUR
PRESIDENT'S OFFICE SAYING, OH,
OUR TITLE NINE OFFICE IS NOW
GOING TO BE UNDER THE
PRESIDENT'S OFFICE, IN A
RESTRUCTURING THING, WE'RE LIKE,
WAIT, HOLD UP. DOES THAT SEEM
LIKE A GOOD IDEA, KNOWING THE
HISTORY THAT WE'VE HAD IN THIS
BROAD CSU TO BE PUTTING TITLE
NINE DIRECTLY UNDER THE CAMPUS
PRESIDENT, AND THERE WASN'T
REALLY ANY CONSULTATION. AND I
KNOW THAT, DOCTOR GARCIA,
CHANCELLOR GARCIA MENTIONED THAT
THE CAMPUSES ARE ALL
IMPLEMENTING THINGS DIFFERENTLY.
RIGHT. AND I KNOW THAT THAT IS A
SPACE FOR INNOVATION, BUT IT
ALSO CREATES PROBLEMS, RIGHT?
WHERE WE'RE NOT GETTING A
THOROUGH IDEA OF WHAT SHOULD BE
DONE, WITH RESPECT TO THAT, AND
I THINK THAT WHAT YOU COULD WORK
ON AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ENVISION IS NOT JUST A PUNITIVE
APPROACH IN TERMS OF
RESOLUTIONS, BUT THINKING ABOUT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE, THINKING
ABOUT A NON CARCERAL APPROACH,
THINKING ABOUT WAYS TO ENGAGE,
FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY
THIS SURVIVORS IN CONSULTATION
WITH DEVELOPING HOW WE DO THE
TRAINING, AND ACTUALLY DOING
PEER BASED TRAINING, FOR
EXAMPLE, AS OPPOSED TO JUST
HAVING THESE KIND OF ONE SIZE
FITS ALL, YOU KNOW, ONLINE
TRAININGS, BRINGING IT IN AND
ACTUALLY DOING SOMETHING THAT'S
MORE LIKE A WORKSHOP WITH
SURVIVORS WHO CAN ACTUALLY SPEAK
TO THE REAL EXPERIENCES HAS A
LOT MORE IMPACT THAN CLICKING
THROUGH A BUNCH OF LIKE,
ILLUSTRATIONS, AND I THINK THAT
THAT COULD BE SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE VERY, VERY IMPACTFUL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
APPRECIATE IT. YEAH, I THINK
WE'RE EARLY IN THE PROCESS WITH
THE CALL TO ACTION BILL PACKAGE
FOR THAT TRUST GAP. SO, YOU
KNOW, AS THAT ROLLS OUT THE BILL
PACKAGE AND THEN WE START
GETTING FEEDBACK FROM ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED, WE'LL BE
ABLE TO GET A BETTER GAUGE OF
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE WE
NEED TO BE AND HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD. WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL YOUR COMMENTS AND
INSIGHTS HERE. AS WE CONTINUE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
REFORMS AND REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE? WELL, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WONDERFUL
COMMENTS. I THINK THOSE ARE VERY
HELPFUL AND INSTRUCTIVE. EACH OF
YOU HAD A UNIQUE THING TO ADD TO
THE CONVERSATION. I KNOW THAT
THE LEADERSHIP OF CSU IS
LISTENING VERY CAREFULLY, AND
WE'LL HOPEFULLY INCORPORATE YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS INTO THEIR THEIR
PROCESS. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
IS THERE ANYONE FROM THE PUBLIC
WHO'D LIKE TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
COMMENT? AND I'D ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO NO
MORE THAN TWO MINUTES SO WE CAN
HEAR FROM EVERYONE. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. I GUESS WE ARE, READY TO
ADJOURN, ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG OR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA, DO
YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING REMARKS
THAT YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE?
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRANK, THANK YOU
SO MUCH, CHAIR HARD. AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO MY COLLEAGUES.
THE CHAIR HART TO CHAIR, NEWMAN
TO EVERYONE WHO'S PARTICIPATED
IN THE ROBUST DISCUSSIONS HERE
TODAY. AS CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE, WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S MORE WORK TO
BE DONE TO REMOVE BARRIERS THAT
NEGATIVELY IMPACT A STUDENT'S
ABILITY TO ATTEND HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS. AND THE
WORK AND EFFORTS AROUND TITLE
NINE REFORM IS SO CRITICAL. I'M
SO GRATEFUL FOR THE AUDITOR FOR
PROVIDING THE UPDATES AND THE
WORK AND EFFORTS GOING FORWARD
TO CONTINUE THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THESE REFORMS AT THE CSU
SYSTEM AND TO THE CHANCELLOR AND
ALL OUR ORGANIZATIONAL
REPRESENTATIVES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY. WE
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA CANNOT
SUCCEED IF A LARGE PERCENTAGE OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS DO NOT FEEL
SAFE ON THEIR CAMPUSES. WE
CANNOT SUCCEED IF THERE'S AN
UNTOLD HUMAN COST AND LOSS OF
POTENTIAL BECAUSE STUDENTS,
FACULTY AND STAFF ARE WALKING
WITH INVISIBLE WOUNDS DUE TO THE
TRAUMA THAT THEY HAVE SUFFERED
AT THE HANDS OF OTHERS, IT IS MY
HOPE THAT THE HEARING TODAY,
COUPLED WITH MY COLLEAGUES, WILL
HAVE THE 12 BILL, A CALL TO
ACTION BILL, PACKAGE WILL SERVE
AS A CRUCIAL STEP IN CREATING A
SYSTEM OF COMPLIANCE AND
OVERSIGHT FOR HOW SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS ARE
HANDLED BY COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WITHIN OUR STATE.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO IGNORE
THIS ISSUE, AND I HOPE THAT
TODAY DEMONSTRATES THE RESOLVE
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS IN
DEDICATING OURSELVES AND
COMMITMENT TO ENSURING THAT ALL
SURVIVORS FEEL SEEN, HEARD AND
RESTORED SHOULD ANYONE, WHETHER
THEY ARE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
OR MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE,
WISH THE OFFICER COUNSEL OR
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW TO BEST
ADDRESS SEXUAL HARASSMENT,
PLEASE CONTACT ASSEMBLY HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE STAFF. I
WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL SHOUT OUT
TO ELLEN FOR HER TREMENDOUS
LEADERSHIP AND EFFORTS ON THE
TITLE NINE REFORM AS WELL. WE
WELCOME YOUR FEEDBACK AND
SUGGESTIONS, AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH AGAIN TO CHAIR HART AND TO
ALL MY COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND EFFORTS ON THIS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, CHAIR
FONG, I APPRECIATE THAT, THANK
YOU ALL FOR ENGAGING IN A
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSION TODAY. I
APPRECIATE THE URGENT ACTIONS
THAT CSU LEADERSHIP HAS TAKEN TO
IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDED
CHANGES THAT WERE CAREFULLY
CRAFTED BY THE STATE AUDITOR.
WHILE IT HAS FULLY IMPLEMENTED
TEN OF THE 16 RECOMMENDATIONS,
WHICH IS A VERY NOTABLE FEAT AND
SOMETHING WHERE I THINK
JUSTIFIABLY PROUD ABOUT, MANY
STILL AGREE THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK TO DO THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN ORDER TO CREATE A SAFER
CAMPUS ENVIRONMENT FOR EVERYONE.
CSU LEADERSHIP MUST REMAIN
STEADFAST IN THEIR EFFORTS TO
IMPLEMENT ALL THE REPORT'S
RECOMMENDED CHANGES. AS CHAIR OF
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE, I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT
THE COMMITTEE WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR CSU'S EFFORTS TO FIX THE
PROBLEMS IDENTIFIED IN THIS
AUDIT. I AM PERSONALLY DEDICATED
TO ADVOCATING FOR THE NECESSARY
CHANGES TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS,
FACULTY, AND STAFF CAN LEARN AND
WORK IN A SAFE, RESPECTFUL AND
SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT. THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
ATTENDANCE TODAY, THIS COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED.